good morning everyone
welcome to the house committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly affairs
we have a number of bills to uh we have
scheduled for hearings this morning but
before we do I'd like you to join me in
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
thank you everyone
the first bill for us to hear about this
morning uh first bill for consideration
is House Bill 262 and I'd like to
recognize the prime sponsor of this bill
uh thank you Mr chair uh I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31.
um
the bill HB 262 that I'm bringing to you
today is a bill that makes good on a
promise that I made two years ago two
years ago uh I I had a bill I think
representative Bill Marsh may have
co-sponsored it with me I know he had
the prior term so it took us two terms
to to get it into place it is now
section 151 colon 12-c I can submit the
current statute around if that's helpful
but but what this statute does
essentially is it allow allows an
individual to go and order their own lab
testing without having a licensed
medical practitioner issue an order
so it was just a little surprising to me
to to have the the neuropath Community
come to me naturopath excuse me
naturopath Community come to me and say
that they wanted to be added to this
bill under where we refer to licensed
medical practitioners and so so all this
bill does
uh is and it's a small bill I assure you
uh Dr Murphy it's this very small little
Bill all it does is it is it adds
naturopathic doctors to that first list
so that they join advanced practice
registered nurses and physician
assistants
so
um I I honestly don't really know what
the scope practice is on a natural path
and how it's distinct from those other
providers and so I asked the uh that
Community uh to come in and and sort of
represent themselves in this bill and uh
because uh I'm I'm do I'm doing this
because I said I would not because I
know anything on the subject
do you have questions for me any
questions something Dr representative
Nagel
um thank you Mr chairman thank you for
that or taking my question
um I just have a question about the
setting in which this is located it's
not referring to lab testing in the
general Community it's listing lab
testing and residential care and health
care facilities
um is that a place that you may not know
the answer but is that the place where
naturopaths actually practice care now
and I'm just curious why it's that
specific
so so
um representative Nagel you may you may
be seeing something I'm not in the in
the current legislation chapter 151
colon 12-c it it it it says a person may
obtain any Laboratory test from a
Clinical Laboratory licensed pursuant to
151 colon 12 IC and and so the the devil
of what the detail is on how a Clinical
Laboratory is defined is is is buried in
in that part of the statute and and I'm
I'm I I didn't dig into that again today
because it's already in statute the
issue today is a narrow one
does this committee wish to add natural
paths to the list of light of licensed
medical practitioners specified in the
opening to the statute
and and I I I frankly not qualified to
know if that's a good idea or not and I
know that there's so many people here
with some substantial clinical knowledge
that I'm really comfortable uh deferring
that uh that judgment to y'all
thank you
yes representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative
Edwards um just a question
um I just want to be clear that when you
add
uh naturopaths to licensed medical
practitioner it is only under this
section and does not you know
um
also allow or potentially involve other
statutes that would be doing other
orderings such as you know MRIs x-rays
or other studies that they would order
would this extend to the ability to
order other types of tests elsewhere in
the medical system no sir this statute
is limited strictly to a self-referral
on a Diagnostic lab result okay thank
you and and and
the extent to which they can do more
than that is already in law under RSA
328-e and and I I don't know what's in
that statute thank you Miss half from
the naturopath is here she can answer
other questions for representative
Edwards
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Edwards um in my understanding of this
this is adding it to the section
Laboratory Testing without a licensed
medical practitioner's order and the
licensed medical practitioners
explicitly not required for this so this
is simply adding naturopaths to the list
of people who are not required for a
prescription is that understanding
correct
hmm I I I I find it odd to say yes
you're absolutely right this is adding
them to a list saying they're irrelevant
to this bill
this legislation I don't get it but but
I don't need to because they're here to
explain why they think that's important
but but your assessment is accurate
thank you
other questions representative Edwards
okay I see none so so thank you I don't
in my lighthearted way to discuss this
bill to be frank with you all to uh I I
may have made light of the naturopath
profession
inadvertently I I'm really just making
fun of my own ignorance on the subject
so there's a little self-deprecating
okay I also signed up to testify this
morning and I'm hoping I'd pronounce the
gentleman's last name correctly Dr Eric
Liu from the New Hampshire Medical
Society
thank you very much
is this on now okay thank you very much
for having me here uh my name is Eric
Liu I'm an associate professor of
pathology at Dartmouth Hitchcock but I'm
here testifying on behalf of the New
Hampshire Medical Society and also the
New Hampshire Society of Pathologists
um so this piece of legislation are uh
would amend RSA 151 colon 12-c to
include naturopathic practitioners among
those other licensed medical
practitioners who would be able to order
laboratory tests uh without having
approval from a licensed uh physician
now there are a few things about this
legislation that that we have concerns
about that we would like to raise to the
committee's attention and and uh
hopefully answer questions if you have
any uh the first is that the RSA 151
12-c pertains to Licensing in the
residential care and health facility
setting
um as Dr Nagel had uh brought up and now
it's unclear why this legislation is
necessary as naturopathic practitioners
typically do not work in the inpatient
setting um hospitals subject Health Care
Providers to credentialing and
privileging process to ensure that
Personnel working at any given Health
Care Facility are qualified and
competent to provide that care and that
their practice doesn't fall outside of
their scope of practice now at this
present time the New Hampshire hospitals
don't recognize naturopathic training or
licensure for credentialing purposes now
we understand that the level of scrutiny
for credentialing is typically not as
rigorous in skilled nursing facilities
and we're uncertain if the naturopathic
practitioners offer services in that
particular setting a concern that we
have about that though is that elderly
or infirm patients that are admitted to
these long-term care facilities might
have
um you know impairments that could
reduce their ability to self-advocate
and these patients might be limited in
their faculty to determine whether or
not certain non-evidence-based workup in
therapy is appropriate or desirable in
their situation
now New Hampshire has deemed it
appropriate to offer State licensure to
naturopathic practitioners but licensure
really should not be treated as an
indication of scientific legitimacy now
according to the uh
aansmc the accrediting agency for
naturopathic medical colleges there are
seven accredited naturopathic schools in
North America and I went online to
peruse their website and it reveals
significant heterogeneity uh in their
curriculums
um and but one thing that's uniform
between all of them is that they impart
core classes in non-evidence-based
curricula centropathic Research
Institute and other like-minded
organizations have proposed that
standard of care treatments as defined
by the aanp shall not shall not be
construed as synonymous with
evidence-based treatments rather
naturopathic Physicians shall have the
broadest latitude for treatment options
that is recognized that advances in
medicine shall come from ideas and
observations from the astute physician
and are then validated by the scientific
method
um and and so
that this there doesn't seem to be a
good standard of care for treatment
um in in the naturopathic Community for
any given disease now furthermore the
curricular exposure to basic sciences
and other clinical courses which could
have grounding in evidence are
significantly lacking when compared to
other traditionally trained medical
practitioners Laboratory test
utilization is one of several areas in
which there's a very stark contrast
between alternative and traditionally
based medical practitioners there was a
2018 study that was performed that did a
review of ordering practices by
complementary on alternative medicine
practitioners in the United States UK
and Australia and they found that
consumers were being exposed to poorly
regulated diagnostic tests and devices
that are being used to make incorrect or
misleading Medical diagnoses in many
cases leading to inappropriate or
harmful treatments and that regulatory
oversight of complementary and
alternative medicine Laboratory Testing
is currently inadequate in all of these
jurisdictions including the United
States you could start wrapping up
certainly
um extensive test utilization and
medically unnecessary testing ordered by
naturopathic practitioners have been a
significant problem for a CLIA
accredited clinical laboratories in our
state
um I you the committee should have
received another testimony from Dr Mark
cervinsky a toxicologist and director
for The Clinical Laboratory at Dartmouth
Hitchcock that kind of outlies some of
those examples so I won't belabor the
point but there are a lot of wasteful
and often expensive ordering practices
that are deemed medically unnecessary
denied by insurers Laboratories and
their Associated facilities are
typically left to shoulder the cost so
we recognize although there's been a
movement for non-discrimination among
Health Care Specialists in our country
but managing things that are
fundamentally different with different
approaches such as the coverage of
proven therapies but not disproven or
unproven therapies is not discriminatory
we think that it's sensible and we you
know think the committee for listening
to my concerns okay thank you very much
question so yes representative Weber
foreign
thank you very much Mr chairman welcome
and thank you for taking my question my
question is simply because we have heard
of concern of over use of these
laboratory tests
if naturopaths can already overuse the
testing what is the point
of including them here when they're
already able to access the testing
um that that's a good question I'm not
really sure what this purpose is we know
that naturopathic practitioners in
Vermont have been able to order tests
and a lot of our orders that we receive
at Dartmouth Hitchcock come from that
area in terms of over over utilization
the sheer volume of testing ordered by
naturopathic practitioners is is Head
and Shoulders above what is typically
ordered by a traditional medical
practitioner and oftentimes repeated
testing like a test that doesn't
actually have a clinical utility that's
based in evidence might be ordered
multiple times whereas it might be
ordered once by a traditional
practitioner
other questions
yes representative
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for being here today
um what is what what skin is it off the
back of the Laboratories to have to do
more tests right I mean somebody's
paying for that right they shouldn't I
mean are you saying that the naturopaths
when they order tests that somehow
that's that's coming that's money coming
out of the pockets of somebody else I
mean who's at the end of the day if
you're a laboratory you like doing tests
like that's what your job is so if
somebody's asking you do more tests me
that should be like Yay more business
what's the skin off their back thank you
the laboratory typically eats the cost
of the test so in general
if an if the naturopathic provider is
ordering it through the patient asking a
physician to order the test for them if
the laboratory doesn't realize this the
laboratory Will Bill the test to the
insurance company the insurance company
will then turn around and say that this
test was medically unnecessary and
refuse payment in that case we would end
up balance billing the patient the
patient has been protected from balance
billing in the United States and so it
will you know they're forced to
um you know we're forced to take the the
in-network median rate at this current
juncture however the patient may or may
not have the wherewithal to
actually pay for themselves or they
might not be have the financial means to
pay for it there's a lot of testing
that's ordered that might be genetic
based that's you know can be thousands
of dollars
um in in total which you know the
patient wouldn't be able to cover by
themselves and the laboratory just eats
the cost in those situations in the case
where
um you know the patient might be a
Medicare or Medicaid patient the
building you know the laboratory would
again would not know that and just build
to Medicare Medicaid uh and and we would
just not get reimbursed
thank you representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman and thank you doctor for
being here
um I understand that this bill is a
little bit confusing are you aware that
this is adding natural paths to a
section that allows individuals to order
their own tests without any involvement
of any practitioner and explicitly
prohibits billing to any third-party
payer and also that it does not require
the lab to to conduct the test but they
may conduct the test are you aware of
those points certainly and and the the
issue that I have is that the types of
testing that are being requested by
naturopathic practitioners are really
quite different than what a typical
individual in the community might order
on themselves you know a typical
Community person you know just wants to
know OG is my cholesterol high or
something they might order a couple of
tests on themselves
um you know which which could be
interesting but if you look at the
ordering practices that the scientific
Community or the clinical laboratories
are receiving from naturopathic
practitioners they run the gamut of of
really expensive esoteric molecular
testing to to look at you know potential
nutritional deficits in patients and and
other things like adrenal adrenal stress
and insufficiency and other things that
don't really have a scientific basis but
thank you and and
um as I'm reading the existing
statute
it refers to the individual
May obtain a Laboratory test from any
Clinical Laboratory that offers the test
to the public on a direct access basis
so am I correct in thinking that that
way the laboratory's liability liability
to have to eat costs is limited by their
choice whether to offer direct access or
not and if we simply
include naturopaths in the definition of
people who are medical providers who may
order the test we are then obligating
the laboratory to provide the test
whether they are guaranteed payment or
not
that's a little bit of a lot to unpack
uh so your your question was if well
sorry
what I'm trying to determine is whether
this is actually exactly like the thing
that we passed the last time which was
putting the onus for payment directly on
the person asking for the test
so presumably in those cases although I
don't know how it's worked out in
practice and I don't actually see the
direct the the payment language in the
statute but I may be missing it
but
in that case the laboratory has to First
decide that they will offer Direct
lab testing which they can decline
and then they get to figure out whether
the person can pay for the services
they're asking for
and in this case I'm asking is that
different
from this case does including the
naturopaths in the medical practitioner
part of the statute create an obligation
in the laboratory
to perform the tests
because the practitioner has the right
to order them
independent of whether the laboratory
will actually get paid by somebody from
doing the tests possibly I'm not
entirely sure okay I'm sorry if you're
not the right person to ask I'll save
that for somebody else thank you
in response though it the billing
process is incredibly complex for the
laboratory and we receive thousands of
tests a day I did reach out to our
Billings specialist at Dartmouth
Hitchcock for the laboratory and asked
them about how how it's handled how
we're able to differentiate
practitioners and who
um who the bill goes to and they weren't
able to tell me off off the top of their
head and it's been a few days and they
hadn't been able to respond to me yet
either so I'm not really sure
um you know how that is determined at
this point
uh actually this King yes we have two
um my question actually is probably more
slanted towards your testimony than it
is towards the bill but it's one that
um I think needs clarification based on
your testimony
and it's just simply uh
I have plenty of data points where
naturopaths are helpful and I have
friends and I and people that I know
what's it going to take for the medical
community to work hand in hand with the
naturopaths
that's a very broad question I it
depends on the scope of practice that is
being asked for and whether or not the
traditional medical community believes
that the scope of practice that they're
asking for is within their
um you know capability and and you know
ability to practice safely without
harming patients I think that's the the
main point
that and I'm not really sure if I can
answer broadly
okay I I appreciate your your candid
answer and I and I apologize too that as
I started this I didn't thank the
chairman for allowing me to ask this
question and thank you for taking the
question
thank you yes
thank you again another representative
yeah thank you again Mr chair
um another question you made some good
answers before and I thank you for that
um and I understand that quite frankly
um there's definitely
um a negative opinion towards
naturopaths within quote-unquote
mainstream medicine however natural
naturopaths do exist and there's a lot
of people that really like that
um and you mentioned that hey there's a
lot of their stuff that isn't
evidence-based but in doing testing
right the goal is to get some evidence
and so it's kind of like a chicken the
egg problem like how can they ever get
the evidence if they're never allowed to
do the testing so my question for you is
have some sympathy here and just put
yourself in their shoes let's say you
you you believe in this field and you
want it to go on what do you believe is
the solution if they shouldn't be
allowed to partake in this sort of
Laboratory Testing what do you think
they should do should they have to like
get their own lab like build their own
labs and do their own tests like what is
the alternative or is it just like nope
they're out of luck tough thank you
I have a point of order Mr chairman yes
if I may sure
um it appears to me this is entirely up
to you but it appears to me that we are
straying well away from the what's on
the bill and well into a philosophical
argument or exploration perhaps rather
than an argument which although it is
fascinating doesn't
actually impact
what is in this bill and we're already
significantly behind time so I wonder if
you want to limit
our discussion to the bill your point is
well taken representative Weber uh may I
address that Mr chair sure go ahead the
reason why I asked this is because
ostensibly this looked like a bill that
I would favor but he's made some very
good points that have made me requestion
you know question things and I would
just like a little follow-up that's all
thank you
okay
doctor are you able to answer that
question it's kind of again off topic a
little bit but the the one of the
concerns is that they're ordering tests
that we don't think that they have the
ability to interpret correctly
um there for example there's a gene
called methyl tetrahydrate folate
um
MTHFR is the kind of the the thing it's
a gene that's in the pathway of of
folate metabolism
um and it's been identified in the
scientific Community like a few decades
ago as being related to people that have
more prone to hypercoagulability meaning
forming blood clots that can you know
potentially cause you to have medical
problems
um but it doesn't have really any
significant bearing on on a person's
overall metabolism and nutritional
um status I guess
um but apparently it's been pretty
common practice for
naturopaths to order genetic testing of
this sort
um you know on genes like this to do a
general biophysical like nutritional
status evaluation and which really
doesn't have any utility at all so you'd
be asking for a test and interpreting it
in a weird way that might you know cause
the patient to think that they have a
disease that they actually don't
that I that that's just one example that
okay other questions more related to the
bill I representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman a very simple
question does the medical society
mm-hmm
I was advised by our society political
advisor to take a neutral stance on this
bill on the Society of Pathologists on
the other hand as opposed to the bill
um I'm not sure if that is helpful to
you or not
it's helpful in the sense that you're
taking no position yeah
it's not helpful okay representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
for taking the question
the way I look at this if I understand
it correctly a natural path can today in
the private office order all the labs
they want
is that correct am I making a correct
statement that I'm unsure of in New
Hampshire I I'm told that's the case in
Vermont but it I was only informed that
this was happening a few days ago and
and I've been on service and busy and I
don't actually know the answer to that
because when I'm trying to make a point
of here is that
this is not dealing with their private
practice as I understand it this is
dealing with them when they go to a
patient that's being institutionalized
or Residential Care
when you in those kind of facilities my
understanding is in order for you to be
a provider within it you have to go
through credentialing
so therefore if you're going through a
credentialing at that point in time with
that in itself screen out the people who
are sort of abusing as you would call it
the system because you have to go
through that process in order to be able
to practice in that environment
theoretically I I suppose so
um I'm not sure if if they're not able
to practice in that setting at the
present time whether this is a move to
increase scope of practice down the road
or not
um
but that that's kind of just my take on
it
so you know other questions okay thank
also signed up to testify is Michelle
half from NHA ND
hopefully I pronounced your last name
correctly
in the sun here we go
uh hello chairman McDonald and members
of the committee my name is Dr Michelle
half I am here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association of naturopathic
doctors we represent roughly 150
naturopathic doctors who are licensed in
New Hampshire
um and I'm hoping I can clarify a lot of
questions this is a very simple bill
that just corrects a technical issue of
us being left off of the bill as a
licensed medical provider that is
already authorized to order and
interpret labs and have we have been in
New Hampshire for nearly 30 years so we
are quite frankly surprised by the
testimony of the medical society who
we've been working very well with since
we were licensed in 1995 and this bill
really has nothing to do with our
ordering practices although I'm happy to
speak on those if we want to go back to
the philosophical argument but I'd
rather stay on task here
um and of Interest I don't believe there
are any naturopathic doctors working in
hospitals or Healthcare facilities at
this time but historically Concord
Hospital did have naturopathic doctors
um practice
um so really what we're just trying to
do here like I said is correct a
technical issue
that makes the bill congruent with the
naturopathic health care practice law
which was passed in 1995 that is RSA
328e which again does allow naturopathic
doctors licensed in New Hampshire to
order and interpret labs so really what
we're trying to address is item three
um from section 151 colon 12 I see it's
um
I could read it if that's useful it
states if a Laboratory test of a person
is conducted by or under the supervision
of a person's other person other than a
licensed medical practitioner and not at
the request or authorization of a
licensed medical practitioner any report
of the test results should be provided
by the person conducting the test to the
person who is subject of the test and
here's the part the sticking point the
report shall state in bold type that it
is the responsibility of the person who
is tested to a range with a licensed
medical practitioner for consultation
and interpretation of the test results
so what I take this to mean is if
someone orders their own labs and then
they bring them to me because I am not
listed as a licensed medical
practitioner right now as it stands this
law lists Physicians which are MDS and
dos nurse practitioners and Physicians
assistants not naturopathic doctors
right so in theory I have to send
someone to one of those people even
though I am inter I am authorized by law
to interpret Labs so this is redundant
so again we're just trying to correct
the technical issue here
um
I think that's really it thank you so
much for taking the time thank you
representative Edwards for bringing
forth this bill and for all of you for
hearing my testimony today happy to take
questions uh representative Leon thank
you Mr chairman and thank you very much
for being here and helping me understand
the point of this sure uh the idea that
this would allow naturopaths to consult
with people who are in uh who need that
consultation
um seems to make a lot of sense you're
aware that um that Memorial Sloan
ketterings cancer center and Swedish
Medical Center all have those integrated
plans with oncology and is this to
replicate that same model here in New
Hampshire throughout our Community
Hospitals
um
I don't know much about that to be
honest yeah I know in many other states
there are naturopaths who work in Cancer
Treatment Centers of America and other
Hospital settings
um but I don't believe there's anyone in
New Hampshire are you speaking of New
Hampshire specifically
um thank you no um we have patients who
do go down to Memorial Sloan Kettering
so there's a matter of whether or not
they'd been Consulting here but that's
helpful to know that while it's not
doing that model it's to allow that
access for people right I mean it's
really to to allow patients to who are
ordering their own labs to bring them to
me and say Here's my interpretation of
it which you know is was part of my
training in naturopathic medical school
we all attend four-year accredited
naturopathic medical colleges and take
national boards Etc so
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
question
so if I understand what you're talking
about is the interpretation of the
results
if we simply go back into the statute
where it says you can be a licensed
medical practitioner
or a natural path would that solve the
problem
well we are a licensed medical
practitioners so but in this part of the
statute they are to say we just refer to
it and add
instead of getting into nuances between
this changing it broadly is getting to
allow the natural path to interpret the
data
by just changing it from medical license
practitioner or an actual path I
understand we're trying to get to this
more of a philosophical argument would
that be sufficient to what you're trying
I mean I guess it would to me it makes
more sense to list us as the licensed
medical practitioner
because we are licensed maybe I'm
misunderstanding the question
thank you I may I'm just trying to find
a way to weave a needle through the
needle I mean perhaps in the future
saying any licensed medical provider
authorized to do blah
you know it's a or it's a common thing
where we're left off and so we're we're
um and I know other providers are as
well yeah
uh yes rep Dr Nagel
thank you representative chairman thank
you for taking my question I'm concerned
that I may be straying into
philosophical but I'll try not to
um I'm a physiatrist I work on
Integrative Medicine I work with a lot
of folks I really believe in what you do
um but in an integrative setting we all
understand our abilities and our
inabilities like for example in my
setting I would never order an MRI of a
shoulder because I don't feel competent
to interpret the results of that
shoulder by law I can order it I can do
whatever I want
um
there's been testimony already about
concerns about naturopaths abilities to
order some very expensive tests and
interpret them and I look at this as
kind of a consumer protection thing but
I'm just curious what your response to
that would be
um I mean there's been a lot of
statements already challenging your
ability to order these things
sure
so again we've been doing this for 30
years Laboratory
um
uh laboratory ordering and interpreting
is a large part of our our both our
didactic training and our clinical
training and naturopathic medical school
as you stated we order a lot of labs we
have a lot of exposure to Labs we um we
have
um really what this comes down to is a
difference in the approach to care we're
trying to get to the root cause of the
issue and often that entails ordering a
lot of labs so we can find out what's
wrong with people so that we aren't you
know throwing darts at a wall in terms
of treatment which in the long run saves
money saves people from having to get
expensive surgeries and be put on
expensive Pharmaceuticals
and so
um
that's that's kind of just a difference
is in the approach to care
um from a state and perspective we are
not authorized to accept Medicaid that
doesn't mean that we don't have Medicaid
patients where we order labs for them
but they're fewer than most practices
and we are also not authorized to
to take Medicare so we're not ordering
labs for Medicare so the cost you know
in this case is goes directly to the the
person ordering the labs but you know in
in other cases is is generally covered
by private insurance
and follow up
um can you do me a favor I really
researched this to try to understand
what goes in a naturopathic education
and I really couldn't find that can you
not now but could you just at some point
just share us what that involves with a
naturopath education is the curriculum
um I'm also concerned about disparity
between schools and things like that it
might be useful if you could email the
committee or something like that sure
I'm happy to do that okay great thank
thank you Mr chair and um thank you in
advance for trying to answer my question
maybe I'm the only one that's confused
but I'm really confused because I hear
people not you but I've heard other
people about
expressing concerns about an increase in
um
prescribing tests that are difficult
that are expensive and difficult to um
interpret
but I heard you say this only refer this
is in a an area of Statute that is about
people ordering their own tests and
self-paying for those tests and it's
only about including natural paths as
um
someone who will be
a profession that will be listed as um
a group that can interpret these tests
so does it have to do with ordering
tests and might it lead to more ordering
of tests or is it only for people who
are
um
independent patients who are
independently getting tests on their own
in this bill is specifically speaking to
those people
I mean in theory it may lead to
additional tests but that's the case
with many provider you know if someone
orders their own labs and then they go
to a provider and they say what does
this mean the provider may say these are
the wrong Labs or we need to do more
testing because this is abnormal so I
don't think it necessarily would involve
more tests or frivolous labs
uh just because they would be
interpreted by a naturopathic doctor
see none
also signed up to testify is our own
Committee Member representative Leah
Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee um in the interest of
time I will keep it very brief there's a
lot of confusion on the point of this
bill
um I'm hoping that I'll just hit those
points and clarify some things
um so it's in the health facility
statute because that's where the
licensing for labs is so we already
passed this bill that people can order
their own Labs that went into effect
January 1st 2023
naturopaths they they can order labs
they can interpret Labs any practitioner
who is given Labs that they don't feel
comfortable understanding from someone
and they didn't order those labs they're
not going to interpret them
um they're going to be brought to
someone who knows how to interpret them
and if a practitioner doesn't they'll
say I'm sorry I can't I don't feel
comfortable interpreting these Labs
whether they're a naturopath or an MD or
a do or NP or what have you
um so lay people can order their own
Labs
um and as far as like expensive testings
and stuff I don't think
um you know regulation necessarily means
effective we see that with lime testing
the Western blot is constant constantly
used for lime testing and we know that
it's very inaccurate I served on a
commission last year we determined we
worked with the state epidemiologists
that the tests are unreliable there are
independent non-fda approved Labs that
are yielding better results that are
um letting people know that they have
Lyme when the Western blot was not
sensitive enough to so um that's a a
side point but the point is that this
just clarifies that naturopaths
um they are not obligated to
to care for a patient who brings them
Labs that they ordered themselves
um and that they have a duty you know a
number four the duty of care it doesn't
include that responsibility
um to review or act on if the request or
authorization of the lab test didn't
come from them so it's just put adding
the protection and I think it's kind of
insulting to tell them that they're not
MediCal practitioners so we should just
say or and after our paths also because
they are licensed medical practitioners
under New Hampshire statute it's a very
simple technical change we just left
them out
and I hope that clarifies what's going
on with the Bill thank you
representative Cushman yes
representative thank you Mr chair it
sounds like without this bill there's
something that they're not allowed to do
and then with this bill there's
something they will be allowed to do can
you just give me a hypothetical
situation where currently right now
because this bill isn't in effect
there's something they can't do that
when this is passed they will be able to
do there's got to be something that they
currently can't do because it's not law
but once this is law they will be able
to do thank you
I think the only thing that they can't
do is
I really don't I really don't think
there's anything that they can't do
without this besides just it clarifies
that they don't have a duty to care for
that patient just because that patient
brings them Labs that they that they had
ordered
no one else has signed up to testify is
there anyone here who wishes to testify
on House Bill 262.
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 262 and
open the house of the hearing on House
Bill 454 and once again recognize its
so uh for the record I'm representative
Jess Edwards Rockingham District
um 31 and uh I I I just want to say Dr
Murphy you were right
yeah
but I'm here today to introduce House
Bill 454 relative to the membership and
Reporting responsibilities of the
Examining Board of Medicine
so what why did this why did this bill
uh come forward to you well
um if you flash back about a year or
more you may recall the Boston Globe uh
looked at a particular physician who
practiced both in Massachusetts and in
New Hampshire and uh saw that there was
a significant discrepancy in how the
Board of Medicine provided transparency
about the complaints against that
particular position and so you know with
the hot glare of the Boston media on it
um it we we the legislature the
HHS oversight in in particular thought
it would be a good idea
to have a subcommittee take a look at
what the board of medicines practices
were and to determine you know to what
extent
systemically uh we had a problem or
systemically we had an opportunity to
solve something or if we were okay so so
the Board of Medicine uh task force of
the HHS oversight got together I
represented another out of them were you
on that no no because I've seen you on
others but anyways chairman Mark Pearson
chaired that and led us through and and
basically what we came to find out is
that you know if the Board of Medicine
receives a complaint they'll act on the
complaint and then they'll determine
whether or not it's appropriate to
provide the public transparency around
that complaint that they've received
there's nothing in New Hampshire law
that requires an individual hospital
dealing with an internal discipline
issue to then go and make that report to
the Board of Medicine and so what we
found was that the Board of Medicine was
not
reporting or not considering reporting
to the public
complaints for which it didn't know
existed which is not a surprise you
can't you don't know what you don't know
they didn't know that there were these
internal complaints
and so looking at the law I could not
find anywhere in the law we could not
find anywhere in the law where the
legislature had directed The Board of
Medicine to keep their eye on individual
Hospital complaints
bring that information in under
particular scenarios evaluate it and
make it transparent to the public
through their their reporting procedures
if appropriate we never told them to do
that and in the Army you never held
anyone accountable for a mission that
you never gave them so we never gave the
Board of Medicine the mission to be
aware of what was going on in the
internal Hospital complaint process and
therefore there there was no pathway
there was no review process in order to
get the uh those internal reports
evaluated determined whether or not they
were significant enough to be reported
to the to the public not all complaints
get reported to the public by the way
there's a due diligence process where
these the Board of Medicine makes that
determination
all right so with that large setup there
were a couple of schools of thought on
what we might do to resolve this this
hole that we identified with the board
of medicines reporting
you know one proposal was to take the
Board of Medicine as is and leave it
alone but create a superstructure board
above it that would evaluate that boards
the board of medicine's Competency and
whether or not they were accomplishing
what they were supposed to accomplish
um and and the Board of Medicine is a
voluntary board the superstructure would
have been a voluntary board and so I I
just don't know how that would work in
real practice you know why would you do
the hard work of being on the Board of
Medicine if you know that somebody else
is going to be looking over your
shoulder and uh and reviewing you so I
just didn't like that approach but but
that still left us with the problem
that we had never given the Board of
Medicine the mission to take a look at
these things and so so my approach to
solving this as well as the uh as the
co-sponsors
representative Leon representative
Pearson was
um let's make sure that we tell the our
Board of Medicine that they are in fact
responsible for uh knowing about these
cases
uh and to go ahead and in some subset of
those cases bring them in for review
and in some subset of those that they
bring into review make a determination
that even though it was an internal
Hospital matter it's still significant
enough to get to the to the uh get to
the public reporting
now
um so so my Approach was give give them
the mission they have they have three
non-clinical providers that sit on the
board of medicine that that's meant to
make sure that there's some public
advocacy of this whole process so of
those three I I what I suggest in this
bill is is that we take one of the three
and say okay you're we're going to give
you the title and I think the title is
in here something about uh you're going
to be designated as the public
transparency Advocate and this person is
going to have some skills on workflow
and basic you know Communications design
and and and that we would let the Board
of Medicine with this Mission new
Mission and this new
capability
go ahead and and do their own assessment
on how to to interact with the hospitals
to get this additional information and
to process it through sort of a a an
informed funnel process so that not
everything that they bring in gets
reported out at the other end but that
there's a discipline method to review
evaluate and report as appropriate so so
this is uh what I would call a light
approach relative to the heavy approach
that was being debated I don't think we
need another superstructure we don't
need to add more government volunteers
looking at volunteers because next
you're going to need volunteers to look
at the volunteers who are volunteering
so so let's just take what we have make
sure that there's Clarity what their
mission is and and deal a little bit
with the resourcing of it without adding
a bunch of money or or weight to that
board
that that's that's what this does
with that I'm uh I'm happy to take
questions yes representative
yeah hi thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I have two quick
ones uh I see Bill 322 is coming up
which is studying
the Board of Medicine and what we should
do about it so I'm just wondering if if
we should wait for that before doing
before doing one thing and then maybe
changing it when we've actually after
we've reviewed
um what the bill 322 leads to which is
establishing a committee to study the
Board of Medicine yeah yes sir and I and
I assume that your chairman uh already
saw that and foresaw that and agreed
because we're hearing these bills again
you know in parallel I'm not a sponsor
of the other bill so
um
the the main question is Vermont has
just gone through sort of the same
process
um with the same concerns that that the
Board of Medicine was missing a whole
lot of stuff that was happening were not
coming out until way later and um so I'm
just curious as to whether you were the
anybody else's has looked at that as a
way to begin to think about this
I'm I'm trying to recall which testimony
we brought in there I've been on so many
of these things uh that I it's hard for
me to remember all of it but I I I I I I
and I think representative Pearson's
here he may be coming up to talk about
this bill and representative Murphy you
were on that right right so so I I think
that was really great that you were on
it because being a practicing physician
engaged directly with Board of Medicine
issues you provided a lot of insight
into that that whole process so I think
this committee will benefit from that
experience and hopefully this bill will
advance the conversation
thank you other questions yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for continuing to engage
on this
I seem to recall a long conversation in
the context maybe of one of the
Christmas tree bills last term
here's my concern I understand that you
have given somebody you've reorganized
the board a bit and given somebody the
duty to look into the transparency
issues however
is there anything in this bill that
creates
and a Duty or even a permission
that relates this person with the
hospitals who apparently as far as I can
read in this bill are still entirely
within their rights not to report that
to this board so the can you either
tell me how this fixes the problem
because they're not going to see the
stuff they're supposed to be transparent
about as I read it or is there a way of
amending this so that they can see the
data that they're supposed to be that we
seem to be looking for that is not
available now and doesn't look to me
like it will be available under this
either so so thank you for the question
I think you were on that subcommittee
too right so so I I had described this
as a as a as a light approach it I don't
view this as the full answer this this
this to me is uh basically uh getting
the Board of Medicine engaged with the
idea that they do have uh some level of
responsibility for what's going on in
the complaints in the hospitals
themselves and gives them a capability
to within the Board of Medicine current
powers
evaluate it and come up with their own
recommendations because they are they
are the Board of Medicine they do a lot
of this evaluation and Reporting ask the
Board of Medicine basically to take a
look at this challenge of internal
Hospital reporting and then within the
physician culture and physician
community and the Health Care system
look to the Board of Medicine to
recommend a legislative path forward so
so I see this as a first step on what
might be a two or three step process but
rather than have the legislature
um you know basically reach in and try
to fix it for them you know I'm I'm
trying to make it so that they're aware
that we we perceive a potential problem
give them a little bit of resource and
kind of expect them to come back with
with some legislative fixes should that
be appropriate if like a voluntary
approach doesn't work so so so this is
my light hand way of of moving Us in the
right direction keeping in mind that
we've had a Board of Medicine For What
over a hundred years you know and and
they've done a pretty confident job
generally you know so so I I don't know
that this is such an urgent thing that
we should as a legislature try to reach
in and fix it for them other than to say
hey we think there's a problem go figure
yes ma'am other questions
I I have my own chair at 10 so I won't
be able to stick around for any
testimony but if there are questions
afterwards I'd be happy to address them
I I think it's great you got two smarter
people from that task force here anyway
they also signed up to speak is
representative Mark Pearson who is the
and a member of Health and Human
Services Alumni Association that's
correct yes previous chairman of this
committee it gets curiouser and curious
sir
representative Edwards spoke to 454 of
which I'm a co-sponsor I hope to speak
to 322 of which I am the prime sponsor
but then there is 655 it is this thick
from Eda uh Edna one bill at a time
representative yes sir
um I would like it to be so and among
other things this reorganizes the entire
oplc
including
the Board of Medicine who it is what it
does and all of that I have a text from
Mr Michael padmore director of advocacy
for the New Hampshire Medical Society
where he has taken the part of the Great
Big Bill that is relevant to the Board
of Medicine and outlines what Edna
wishes to do so we've got the battle of
the bills and I personally would hope in
the next few days before Edna execs this
on Friday or has their work session that
there can be some coming together
to do what I hope the next bill 322
tries to do and that's bring the
relevant people together sit down and
work it out some legislators
hospitals the Board of Medicine and so
on so I'm just simply saying it is even
more complex than representative Edwards
just mentioned based on what I found out
yesterday
questions for representative Pearson
representative Weber just quickly the
the number of the bill that's in Edna
because 650 655 I haven't ah no wonder I
couldn't find it thank you I haven't had
the chance to find out exactly where in
655 the relevant part is but it's in
there
representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Pearson
um I want to get back to a question that
was asked before because I want your
opinion on this um I think the goal is
Honorable and I I'm fully aware that
there's issues in terms of reporting
within individual institutions the Board
of Medicine
I I'm struggling to understand how 454
addresses that and how that will make a
difference in that particular issue
which is what apparently brought this
bill forward so I'm curious
does this bill have value your name's on
that is the bill that is more
particularly driven by representative
Edwards I signed on to it because in
effect it was kind of a Minority Report
of the subcommittee I had created and I
wanted to honor that uh the majority or
at least what I hope is is the bill
other questions representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman welcome back it's
good to see you mark
what I want to follow up on what uh
representative Weber talked about before
in here talks about a true record of the
board's official acts my concern is that
a lot of times many things we're talking
about are discussed in non-public which
become sealed records
so in saying that we're trying to get to
the transparency of the medical board
and what's happening within the medical
community
if we can't have access or somehow some
summary coming from the non-public side
is that going to impact what you have
here as far as the public records
in my opinion there are certain
judgments that should be public and
certain ones that should not be for
example
the Board of Medicine of Massachusetts
reported 20 malpractice settlements
against the Manchester surgeon in
question that's too much information or
not enough information how many of those
malpractice settlements were because of
egregious medical misconduct with a huge
seven-figure payout and how many of
those were the kind of thing most
professionals including my wife dread
somebody sues for thirty thousand
dollars and your insurer says it costs
us 50 to defend it we'll give them 30 to
make them go away I don't know which is
which from what Massachusetts uh
reported in New Hampshire reported none
of that and what my hope in 322 the next
bill is is that as these things are
being discussed there will be criteria
as to what should be told and what
should be buried the former should be
told the latter should be buried
follow-up representative
thank you Mr chairman so this bill the
way it's written really doesn't address
that
you would wish to speak to
representative Edwards I'm affirming his
right to file a Minority Report to a
subcommittee thank you welcome
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I want to hug the
baby very soon okay
um my question is
um do you think it's just generally a
good idea to ensure that one of the
public members
um On The Board of Medicine
um should be a transparency Advocate
regardless of what's been going on with
the Board of Medicine right now don't
you think do you believe that it's just
generally a good idea to have that
position on the board I think the entire
board should adopt good rules of
transparency that protect the innocent
seeing no other questions
okay thank you representative thank you
sir
also signed up to speak today is Shane
Goulet an attorney for the New Hampshire
Mr chairman Representatives my name is
Shane Goulet I'm an attorney for the
office of professional licensure and
certification I'm here today in a very
specific capacity as board Council for
the Board of Medicine I'd just like to
say at the outright the Board of
Medicine takes no position on this they
just wanted me to come to speak to the
committee to highlight some potential
concerns and I think representative
Merchant kind of took the win right out
of my sales with part of it as it
relates to the fact that I'm going to go
to the italics here and we're at one of
the public members shall be designated
as the public transparency Advocate the
public transparency Advocate shall be a
person who through background or
training and without conflicts of
interest is capable of exercising
systems analysis and providing
recommendations to improve public
transparency of the board
responsibilities under subparagraphs to
B and C those two sub paragraphs deal
with the complaints and investigatory
process the board of medicine its main
obligation is public protection they
take that very seriously but they also
are within the confines of 91a3 which
I'm just gonna go we have 91a3
subsection 2C matters which if discussed
in public would likely affect adversely
the reputation of any person
complaints are discussed in non-public
because they are in the complaint
process 329 illustrates that further
during the complaint process that
information is not to be disclosed to
the public pursuant to their own statute
so while taking no position they just
wanted to highlight and express to the
committee that that is a barrier as it
relates to what if anything could the
public transparency individual stay
during these meetings outside it would
be basically related to process and
procedure which are Illustrated in the
rules and the statute of the Board of
Medicine
that's all I have to say thank you thank
you uh questions yes Dr uh
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking this
question can you help me understand how
having a transparency Advocate with the
capability of exercising CIS CIS systems
analysis
how that person with that skill would
make more information from the hospitals
transparent which the hospitals are not
giving to the board
I I don't think that that necessarily
would be the case I think that it would
be have to be a value on an individual
you know situation the concern of the
Board of Medicine was not related to
that piece necessarily but to how much
Insight the public transparency member
could provide from the internal meetings
of the Board of Medicine that occurred
in non-public not necessarily that piece
representative
okay thank you you're welcome
other questions representative Merchant
oh representative representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here today
um I as you've looked at 93 sorry 91a3
I'm sure you've seen that there are
certain expectations around police
officers when sometimes it rise Rises to
the level of public concern something
that could impact their reputations uh I
I see the potential of this of this
Advocate as identifying where there may
be legislation in the future in order to
know where that dividing line is between
privacy and patient protection
do you have any insight as to whether
that's a correct or incorrect
interpretation
well I think without getting into a
legal analysis here I'm I'm authored in
a very limited scope here today I will
say as far as because I've heard it
discussed and I hope this addresses your
question somewhat
um that there is emergent circumstances
which necessitate the emergency
suspension of a license pursuant to 91a
the board is authorized to have
emergency meetings and they will
emergently suspend an individual's
license when there's a determination
under 541a 29 3 I believe that there is
imminent danger to Public Health and
life that suspension occurs and that is
a public document okay and that
individual is then that's done in the
next part type ex parte basis that
individual then has that opportunity to
be heard in 10 days but as soon as that
order is made the emerging suspension
that is post and that's public document
because at that time there was a
reasonable basis for the board to
believe that there was an imminent
danger to Public Health in life so I I
know that kind of was part of it but I
didn't I couldn't do the whole question
follow-up representative thank you Mr
chairman and thank you that gets almost
all of it um the other question is if
the that public transparency Advocate
would be
um aware of those in issues that may
Simply Be residing at the hospital level
and not coming to the board or if that
requires a larger effort to change that
would not be seen by that public
transparency advocate
well I think as far as the hospital
piece the board is you know a
quasi-judicial entity uh making you know
judicial determinations on whether or
not somebody's license should be
suspended and I think five you know 329
illustrates a process and procedure that
kind of separates the Board of Medicine
from that investigatory process to some
extent so they can remain neutral
Arbiters when it comes to the point if
it comes to the point that they need to
find misconduct or Institute discipline
your presented a merchant thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking the question
having served on the Board of Pharmacy
for 10 years they can still understand
what you're talking about again
non-public versus public
I would also say that this issue is not
just remained to the Board of Medicine
it's also dealing with where the
practitioner practices which is the
hospital side there's nothing in here
talking about holding the hospital
accountable
for the practitioner as well strictly
the Board of Medicine so why are we only
looking at the Board of Medicine and not
um I don't think that I have the ability
the board took a limited vote as to what
my testimony could be I could bring that
back to the Board of Medicine
um we meet every month the first
Wednesday of every month and try to
ascertain their position on on what
their take on requiring a hospital to
report would be
um I know that they're they're in favor
of transparency in general
so and which is why they're taking no
position but just wanted to speak I'm
sorry I couldn't answer that that's fine
in totality mail the committee that
would be great okay if you're able to do
that thank you other questions
I see no other questions I'm sorry yes
I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I'm obviously a very big fan of
transparency or why I've signed on as
co-sponsor in the next bill 322.
um but I'm trying to think about
mechanically in a hospital
how a transparency Advocate would be
able to get access to complaints which
are usually internally you know
generated in dealt with in a hospital
setting
um representative Pearson said that you
know this is not available to the Board
of Medicine suspensions and you know
privilege revocations are you know are
reported to the Board of Medicine but
complaints are not for an obvious reason
I'm trying to understand or maybe you
could explain me how an advocate could
actually penetrate to get the complaints
and have them somehow aired from within
the hospital to this advocacy person
um I I don't know
um necessarily how to answer that
question because they're you know the
Board of Medicine has authority over
very specific things
um as Illustrated within 329 most of
which relates to the licensure
qualifications the investigatory process
and discipline their authority to
enforce anything over third parties for
non-compliance with their own
obligations under the statute is
somewhat limited and I'm speaking in a
general colloquial sense because that
there are only certain specific
individuals who are obligated to report
whether it be insurance companies
malpractice claims the court system for
civil uh litigation that's been filed
for medical malpractice claims there are
obligations on those individuals as
currently constructed under 329 but the
enforceability of the Board of Medicine
well first of all whether or not there
is information that they know exist and
isn't getting
they wouldn't know that and if they did
have that information the authority to
do anything about that I don't see
currently
um within their statute necessarily that
I hope that kind of answers the best I
can they kind of authorize me to talk
within the constructs of 329 in their
specific position on this bill so I'm
sorry that I couldn't give you
everything no thank you somewhat of a
rhetorical question but thank you okay
missing anyone listening okay thank you
very much thank you um my statements uh
for the following boat were the exact
same but I would like to testify if
there was any further follow-up as to
that bill as well okay if you want to
pull out a pink card you can just find
that thank you very much thank you
anyone else uh who wishes to testify I
have no other people signed up
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 454. okay
and I am gonna
parliamentary inquiry yes sir
sponsors and co-sponsors can get up and
testify however under certain chairman
that it has been that sponsors and
co-sponsors cannot question
the person testifying and uh and some
have not so I thought since I'm a
co-sponsor and not somebody else I'm is
there it's the question is what what is
your that's why I think I should I can
answer that representative Weber uh we
had an amendment to house rules that was
voted on so it's now not up to the
chairs it is in-house rules and the
sponsors and co-sponsors may choose if
they are going to speak in which case
they may not question or not speak in
which case they may question that is
different from our practice before but
it's up to them they can do one or the
other but they can't double dip thank
you very much
thank you representative Weber and
representative McKay
okay as I was saying I am closing the
public hearing on House Bill 454 and I
am opening them public hearing on House
Bill 322. and accordingly represent
welcoming back representative Mark
Pearson who is the Prime sponsor of a
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee in addition to other aspects
of my biography I am part-time CEO of a
family practice medicine counseling
massage center in Kingston
so needless to say I've talked at Great
length with my pcps especially and the
motto I've adopted now over several
months is I want to protect the innocent
who are accused and expose the guilty
and that is
tooth those are two things which are
very important to me I'm going to skip a
The Honorable Jeffrey soloway who for
six years was a member of this committee
and for I think two years at least was a
member of DHHS oversight with me was the
one that got the ball rolling on all of
this about transparency and why does
Massachusetts report certain things on
their Board of Medicine website that New
Hampshire does not especially when
persons in question are from New
Hampshire
we met as a subcommittee on the fly on
October 3rd 17th and 31st knowing that
if we're gonna
submit legislation we've got to do it
pretty quickly
we came to a couple of conclusions in
our subcommittee
we were told that investigations of
complaints received by the Board of
Medicine were given to a part-time
volunteer retired physician while
commending him for his service and
having no evidence that he was not doing
his job well we wondered if the
investigative arm of Board of Medicine
needed additional Staffing and
compensation for time and expense
this question is being addressed by
House Bill 445 that will give to oplc
the ability to keep some of its funds
presently the funds are lapsing when
they receive monies from people renewing
licenses and I know because I've signed
the checks not all of that money is
expensed by the boards in other words
they make a profit that money goes back
to the general fund 445 asks the
question wouldn't it be good for oplc to
keep some money so that when something
arises quickly we don't have to wait for
the whole budget process we could hire
we could have hired an investigator a
couple of months ago if that was
necessary so we saw the funding as one
of the issues and then we looked at the
question of the rules
what are the rules for what should be
reported to the public we can be told
well the law says this and that with the
legislature we can change those laws
what needs to be reported Massachusetts
obviously has a different way of doing
it in their Board of Medicine than we do
is there way better is our way better
could we examine the way could we
examine has there been breaches of the
rules that are good have there have been
occasions where we think the rules need
to be tweaked that second conclusion has
led to the bill before you 322 the bill
would take that short-lived
temporary subcommittee
that looked at these questions under the
auspices of DHHS oversight and turn it
into a study committee that would look
at all of these things bringing relevant
people together
and ask the question other rules what
they should be what should be disclosed
to the public what shouldn't be and I
gave an example in response to
the bill as I the LSR as I turned it in
didn't quite
get reflected in the bill as it came out
so there is an amendment 386 I'll give
you all copies of this because you're
going to exec this pretty soon it makes
a few very brief changes to the bill
that you do have before you number one
it lowers the number of senators from
three to two there's only 24 of them and
bazillions of positions they have to
fill on committees and a lot of times
they just can't be in three places at
once it lowers it to two the Senators
have thanked me for that also it does
something that we do in oversight and
that is it also names a few house
members as alternates and I see some
alternates or past alternates to
oversight here this means the alternate
comes can participate can do whatever
and be raised to the level of a regular
member if somebody's absent that's
hopeful to get wisdom that's also
helpful to make a quorum
thirdly I suggested that the committee
report to oversight semi-annually and
not quarterly there'll be a lot of
oversight I mean excuse me overlap
between oversight and this committee
should it be established
fourthly the committee will sunset on
June 30th of 2026. this is important I
think for a lot of folks that things
sometimes will sunset and not just be a
committee that is there in his dad
uh if you read through the uh people who
will be on the committee you will notice
something different
we passed
a law that said
on committees like this commissions like
this
the majority had to be legislators
and if we wanted all of these other
folks from stakeholder groups to be on
the committee to vote we would have to
put on a lot more legislators so I
worked with OLS and we came up with this
thought what if we said we would really
encourage somebody from the hospital
Association to be there as a regular
participant what if we had somebody from
and there's the list as non-voting
people
as people however who would come and
participate greatly in the process that
seemed to pass muster so if you wondered
why are these people non-voting that's
having
just discovered the big uh oplc
redo bill that Edna has come up with one
of the things I hope to do today and
tomorrow is talk with Eda to see
what they have in their bill and what we
have or I haven't you have and this bill
uh there can be some melding uh I just
don't want two things to pass that
contradict each other
so that's
um that's why I'm more winging the
testimony is because this is late
breaking news
I've got a copy for everybody of my
original testimony which is not wrong
but it just has a lot of stuff in here
you don't need to have me say and I also
have a copy of for everyone of that
amendment that I would ask Mr chairman
you ask somebody to introduce when you
exact with your permission sir may these
be passed around absolutely okay go
ahead and also representative piercing
knife could you make sure you complete a
pink card
yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you um for
taking my question welcome back again
and again and again
um so
this seems like uh to me like a little
bit of a hybrid between a commission and
a and a study committee given that it's
got other regular uh members but they're
not voting members and um I like this
idea very much
um and I was a little concerned when you
said it was sunset in 2026 is your
expectation that there will be
um concrete ideas for
um legislation that might solve some of
the problems that people
saw when the you know when the specific
Spotlight article came out and I think
it was pretty alarming so
can you say what your expectation is
about when there'll be some solutions
offered
a lot of good work has been done already
I've had good conversations with Dr
Emily Baker from the Board of Medicine
and the hospital Association and all
these people you're mentioning here or
the bill mentions here as adjunct
members
um we're very much part of this process
already this is just getting the band
back together and frankly before this
actually kicks in should this pass and
be signed into law over the summer well
before then one of the things I hope to
do as
re-elected chairman of oversight is to
get another subcommittee going that
replicates this what this bill is doing
is giving an official status in law to
that
but a subcommittee can certainly do a
lot of the prep work and hand things on
to whatever committee is signed into law
as for 2026 I probably will be chairman
of fish and game at that point and uh
um
if we're done we're done if we're not a
yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Pearson I have a hearing
loss Dr Palmer if you could be a little
closer to the mic thank you sir so thank
you and
one of the pieces that I would love to
see incorporated into this and I wonder
if you have thought of this is the whole
issue of the hospital peer review piece
I'm on a hospital peer review committee
that happens to be in Vermont and we've
just gone through a lot of this whole
issue about that that the tension
between hospitals releasing stuff to the
Board of Medicine and you know at one
point it was very heavy-handed they
wanted everything the Board of Medicine
which was not going to be practical but
also would would would quell
people reporting things within the
hospital which is extremely important
because you want to be able to not just
out the guilty but also figure out what
systems in the hospital aren't working
properly so I just wonder if that's
there's nothing specific about a peer
review person being on this committee
but
I guess I'm asking if that would be
something that might make sense
Dr Palmer when I was reestablished the
subcommittee would you like to come
sure thank you
yeah I I mean you I think a lot of you
know that I'm a middle bowl of porridge
kind of guy and you know I really like
to find that sweet spot in the middle
when possible and that's what I hope to
do here uh no we do not want the names
of people outed prematurely if it's a
system problem let's fix the system
good folks sincerely acting sometimes we
need to change the the rules a little
bit and good folks will want that people
unjustly accused we don't need to know
about that the public doesn't need to
know about that that needs to be very
quietly buried after it was investigated
and proven to be a non-issue we're
talking about the outrage of people who
telephone me maybe some of you when the
globe Spotlight or articles came out a
few of them in the union leader but a
lot of them in the globe when that came
out I get phone calls from people who
knew the individual in question and by
the way this individual in question is
not the only individual whose
malpractice settlements were not
reported in New Hampshire but were
reported elsewhere this is not the only
one I get a lot of outrage I got a lot
of outrage from Physicians remember my
wife is a family practice physician I go
to their parties they talk to me they
say do something and that's what I want
this to do is protect the innocent fix
the systems and when necessary find out
who's doing something
egregiously wrong and make it known so
the public has better confidence in the
medical establishment
other questions
do I understand correctly that where are
you trying to head
is to the authority of the oversight
committee to form committees and to as
part of the responsibility and am I
correct and that's where you're heading
and I should tell you that I have a
committee that I want to bring over as
well you're always welcome
thank you what I hope to do is have 322
as amended past so it can be in law
that says something that says As A
legislature We Care
if this sails through and the governor
signs it I have a feeling the committee
will not start meeting until late summer
early fall
I want to get going now so I want to get
the ad hoc subcommittee back and running
to do what this bill asks and probably
with most of the people this bill names
so that a lot of the work is already
done so when this bill is signed into
law
a lot of the work has been accomplished
already but I see this two-prong
approach the subcommittee is immediacy
this is officialdom this is good stuff
and uh
I asked OLS because I've used the term
committee and commission interchangeably
apparently now
committee is legislators
committee and non-committee but as
that clears up my interchangeability
problem of terms thank you
yes representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um does the scope of this bill as just
as currently written covered
um does it allow the committee to look
at conflicts of interest within the
Board of Medicine and if not should it
we're looking at rules we're looking at
how things are done how things are
received how things are evaluated and
how things are reported I would see this
would have some broad scope
and as uh the late excuse me I I just
killed him I didn't mean that the great
if we dealt with every conflict of
interest in New Hampshire half the work
wouldn't get done anymore
this conflict of interest in this
conflict of interest into my back pocket
with large denominated money I think
sometimes
people who have an interest in an issue
can bring things to the table the
question is at what level is conflict of
okay other questions
yes representative uh thank you chairman
and thank you it's not really a question
I just noticed that we're hearing uh
Bill 323 but your amendment is numbered
322.
and so that might need to be corrected
oh okay 323 is it wonderful I withdraw
my comment okay thank you other
questions
I'm seeing no other questions thank you
representative I will fill out a pink
card I will thank you you're welcome we
appreciate that the clerk and I
okay also signed up to testify today is
David cuzzy from the New Hampshire
Association a New Hampshire Society of
you have about three minutes sir
I'll be less than that Mr chairman I
appreciate it uh good morning members of
the committee uh my name for the record
my name is David cuzzy with Prospect
Hill strategies here in town uh this
morning before you as the chairman said
on behalf of the New Hampshire Society
of physician assistants I did send in a
letter by email from the from the PAs to
everyone uh we're supportive of the bill
with uh some what we think are some very
simple changes uh we noted that Pas were
left out entirely from this bill even
though its Physicians and PAs are the
ones regulated by the Board of Medicine
uh we also noted with some level of
curiosity that that nurses were included
uh in the bill even though of course
nurses are not regulated by the Board of
Medicine they have their own
uh regulatory structure uh so we would
respectfully suggest
and this is nothing against the nurses
of course
um but we would respectfully suggest
there are three places within the bill
that have nurses that we would kind of
uh Delete and and add Pas very
specifically on page one of the bill
line four
uh it currently reads a member of the
New Hampshire Nurses Association excuse
me I'm sorry I got ahead of myself on
page one
line 15 uh it it says uh after Medical
Association the association of nurses uh
we would respectfully suggest that that
say the New Hampshire Society of
physician assistance instead of the
association of nurses
on line 27 page one uh at the very end
of that line it says reports of lapses
in physician we would add uh and
physician assistance physician assistant
practice
I was scribbling while you I'm sorry I
started the second one so could you tell
us of course my apologies I got line 15.
you got line 15 line 27. okay thank you
I beg your pardon right at the end where
it says it it would go uh from line 27
to 28 it says lapses in physician
practice we would say physician and
physician assistant practice or
physician assistants practice how
whatever the
grammar would be they don't they didn't
pay me to be an English teacher
and then uh
with your Indulgence Mr chairman on page
two line four
uh where it's as a member of the New
Hampshire Nurses Association we would
respectfully suggest that that be
changed from The Nurses Association to
the New Hampshire Society of physician
assistance
um I think
if there's a desire to keep nurses
involved that's obviously a policy
decision I think what's most important
for the Pas is that they're included as
a regulated entity by the Board of
Medicine and that's all I have Mr
chairman of course I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you yes sir representative Nagel
just a quick question and excuse my
ignorant oh thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question
um excuse my ignorance but are you the
only organization that represents the
Pas in the state
uh thank you for the question
representative as far as I know yes
and we have about a thousand Pas that we
that we recommend
excuse me that we represent
other questions representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman also thank you for
taking the question you raised a really
good point about the membership on the
or open fuel assemble the commission is
a committee with hybrid
earlier this morning we talked about
another
license Medical Professional and
relationship to ordering and
interpretation of blood work
those individuals were naturopaths
should they be part of this
I
I don't know that we have a
position one way or the other I don't I
don't know uh I'm not intimately
familiar with who regulates them and
whatnot
um so I'd I'd defer to others on that
one uh thank you for the question by the
way representative I defer uh this but
would defer on that I think I heard the
answer uh there's it's a different board
so I think that's that's what I thought
thank you
okay go ahead oh I'm sorry go ahead
representative Weber
we have had a long-standing tradition
sometimes not observed under our past
chair here
that people only get one bite at the
Apple and that responses may be made
afterwards in any way that people think
appropriate but
only you testify once and then you're
done and we don't do a back and forth
and I think it very inadvisable to get
into the back and forth because that way
even when it's the sponsor of the bill
is is unfair to other people all of whom
want to also respond so
I would advise against it but it's up to
you
thank you and again
um
representative Weber you have a long um
tradition and a great deal more
experience than I do
um and other there are other people who
have signed up to testify so
representative Pearson I don't know what
your schedule is this morning but you're
welcome to stay and perhaps at the end
if you're able uh you can address that's
concern and perhaps any other concerns
um so any other questions for Mr Cousy
I guess I'm seeing none so thank you
okay I also signed up to testify uh is
Dr Eric Liu from the New Hampshire
again I'm here on behalf of the medical
society and thank you for having me
um if uh we really want to thank
representative Pearson for heading that
committee uh from the last fall uh over
looking over the board of medicine's
disciplinary process and governing
statutes as the committee did find the
New Hampshire Board of Medicine really
needs to seek additional funding through
the state's budget project uh process
and that more study is really needed to
understand if changes are made to the
board's disciplinary process
um we we really thank representative
Pearson for all of the hard work that
he's done in for introducing HB 322 we
also agree with Mr Cousy in that it
would be a good uh process to include
PAs
to provide input into the process and we
strongly urge the committee to pass HB
322 so we can continue the work that was
started
oh that was great short and sweet
also signed up to speak is Paula menahan
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Parliament hand
senior vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all our
hospitals we are in support of three of
House Bill 322 and we appreciate all the
work that representative Pearson has
done to date on this um important issue
the issues that the study committee
shall explore are complex and important
to ensure the proper balance of
proceedings of the board of Med medicine
and safeguarding the safety of patients
being treated by physicians this is why
we do support this committee and we urge
you to pass house bill 322.
that's it oh wow that was quick any
I'm seeing none so thank you very much
also signed up to testify is Shane
Goulet from the New Hampshire Board of
Medicine
thank you Mr chairman Representatives
um I'll be short on this one as I think
that the board again takes no position
on this
um the concerns they have are their
restrictions as far as 9183 were
concerned uh outside of that you know
it's the primary responsibility of the
board of medicine to protect the public
they're in favor of transparency within
the confines of the legal structure as
it's currently exists with that being
said open up for questions
uh yes go ahead representative palazzov
thank you Mr Chen thank you for taking
my question do you have any position on
the proposed amendment to replace gnosis
with bpas Association oh as far as the
Pas
um because I don't have a authority to
speak on behalf of the Board of Medicine
as it relates to that I the Board of
Medicine can't take a position through
me I will say that the Board of Medicine
does have the authority over Pas
um as they you know 329 is currently
constructed there is a PA member of the
Board of Medicine I don't know if that's
seeing none
okay thank you very much thank you very
much
okay no one else has signed up to speak
representative Pearson would you like to
Mr chairman having thought about it I am
going to strenuously object to giving
the prime sponsor a Last Licks after
everybody else is testified it has not
been our practice or our custom and I
really think it's very unfair to
everybody else who testifies on the bill
and I say that with the greatest of
respect and also kind friendship for
representative Pearson whose remarks are
often very helpful
see um again I'm I'm new to this job I I
have to admit that but at the same time
representative Weber it hasn't happened
before and it sounds like he has
information that might answer some of
the questions that were raised and Mr
chairman your predecessor was a lot
sloppier on this
no anyway which doesn't mean it's a good
or a bad idea but my new best friend Mr
cuzzy and I went out in the hall and
guess what I'm going down to
OLS and redo the amendments to add the
PA Association however not at the
expense of the nurses because this is
inputting this is not about who we're
regulating there's people who are going
to show up to help us understand that
will not eventually be regulated per se
but they have a stake in it okay so
that's all it's new information my new
best friend and I have come to a
wonderful agreement and I'm going to
give you a new amendment when you exact
the bill okay so so the mat has been
addressed and it sounds like we're well
okay I know no one else signed up to
testify uh does anyone in the audience
wish to testify who has not uh yet
signed up
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 322 and
open the house uh the public hearing on
House Bill 299 and in doing so I am
going to recognize the prime sponsor
foreign
yes
thank you Mr chair thank you members of
the committee for inviting me here to
introduce my bill HB 299 for the record
my name is Mike Belcher representative
from Carroll County District 4 out of
Wakefield
the first thing I would like to say
about this bill
um as it relates to anti-discrimination
is that there was nothing removed from
current law so all existing
anti-discrimination stands what I have
done is I have sought to add
certain specific protections that have
been necessitated by some fairly recent
developments within the field of
medicine and how it's practiced how it's
what you will see here is that there is
a new trend in medicine there's various
names for it sometimes it can be
referred to as Health Equity
sometimes it could be referred to as
Justice
sometimes it can be referred to as
anti-racism
um and they all kind of they don't
they're not exactly the same definition
for each of those words but they have an
area of overlap that covers what I'm
trying to get to in this bill now
I think we can all agree that
when you're dealing or rather when a
healthcare provider is dealing with a
patient they have an individual sitting
in front of them it's a person
it's not an avatar of some combination
of groups
it's a person with specific needs for
their specific health condition at the
time
therefore they should not be treated as
merely an avatar of their race or their
sex or whatever else now that doesn't
mean you can't take these things into
consideration because obviously there is
importance in the administration of
Health Care that a man and a woman are
going to have different needs
even sometimes people of different races
may have different needs depending on
the way conditions affect them and
that's all fine there's nothing wrong
with that however
you will see along the things that I
have passed out a very important quote
that really gets to the heart of what
we're dealing with in some of this new
ideological push within Healthcare
um Dr Ibrahim X kindy author of the book
how to be an anti-racist he's coined the
term
he is the head of the Institute of
anti-racism at Boston University they
promulgate a lot of this sort of policy
his quote says and this this really
encapsulate what anti-racism and Health
Equity means at its core
the only remedy to pass discrimination
is present discrimination
the only remedy to present
um honorable members of the committee I
do not think we want to set up a system
where we have a Perpetual cycle of
punishment and retribution
as a part of our system
and that is why I have added
the specific language in this bill
that makes it
it prohibits
the
consideration
of alleged
historical
injustices that could be very real
against any group
when it comes to the current
administration of Medicine
to a real person who is standing in
front of a healthcare provider
and that's that's what I'm trying to do
here I I just I don't want to see this
discrimination happening and it is it's
here it's come here
you'll see an article here from the New
York Post written by a ex-lutenant
governor talking about how these um
ideas have been promulgated at the
federal level and down
you'll see you may note that within this
state
both the covid vaccinations initially
when they were a very rare commodity as
well as monoclonal antibodies
word
um were rationed in exactly this manner
and it was wholly inappropriate to do so
in fact there were civil rights
complaints filed with the state because
of the way that was handled
um
that's all I have for you I'd be happy
to take questions
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for bringing this bill to
us
um I I recognize that some of this is
coming from current events but do you
think that if we were able to take this
back in time to the Tuskegee experiments
if this would have prevented the
um the denial of care of people infected
with syphilis in the black community
there in order to watch the spread and
if that would remedy if this would have
been a remedy back then and would
prevent any future racism in any
direction well clearly yes that is that
is that is part of what this is designed
to prevent now people break the law so
would it have actually prevented it if
people wanted to do a horrible thing I
can't be 100 sure but this is designed
yes it would in theory at least prevent
something like that from happening
thank you
yes representative thank you chairman
McDonald thank you for being here today
and taking questions
if I a biological male
went to a gynecologist and that
gynecologist told me to get out of his
office or her office would that
um would that doctor open themselves up
to legal problems because of your
legislation thank you
thank you for that question and that is
a question that I think is answered in
existing statute because the portion of
this
um statute that would address that
particular concern is already law
that is not something that has been
changed whatsoever so I think the answer
is no they would not be opening
representative whoever did you have your
hand up
I did but I think I'm gonna withdraw
that because
um I don't think I can ask a question
and not have a debate so thank you Mr
chairman thank you
is representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question representative uh I'm wondering
is there
how is this going to be enforced
um thank you for the question and an
excellent question
um there is not a specific state
enforcement mechanism however it does
create a private cause of action for
people who have been aggrieved and
discriminated against and have been
and I believe that's wholly necessary
considering the the fact that this is a
a well-funded
um
effort to place this in medicine
representative Weber I actually have a
question of the chair which is is this
uh Bill going to either
um is is this bill going to go to uh the
Judiciary Committee after this or is
this just a plain it's my understanding
it will only be the one committee bill I
from what I understand representative
okay thank you other representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking the question
um you said that this kind of
discrimination excuse me this kind of
discrimination has indeed occurred in
New Hampshire can you give a more
specific details about that yes despite
being prescribed I was denied monoclonal
antibody treatment
it was uh promulgated the guidelines
were promulgated at the federal level
and pushed down the way that they ranked
people in order to receive the scarce
resource of monoclonal antibodies for
covid-19 infection was by a scoring
system in which they they only placed a
minor
um emphasis on prehisto a pre-existing
medical conditions and other and other
truly medical problems but they praised
follow-up follow-up
um do you feel that there are any
circumstances which under which
underserved
communities
should be given some kind of priority to
make sure that they are served
I believe that all communities should
have equal access to the system I
believe that they should be served
um
not at the expense of other people but
given the same opportunities
do you have any documentation that the
preferences that were established
that included
race if that happened because I don't
know but I'm taking this on face value
were not as a result of past
discrimination
but as a result of the current medical
evidence
that certain
segments of the population
experienced higher and far more severe
consequences than did other segments of
the population can you discount that
thank you for the question I would I
would offer two different tracks on that
question which is first because the
because the guidelines that were
promulgated at the federal level
placed I believe a seven times higher
emphasis on Race than pre-existing
medical conditions I would say that
alone is enough to seriously question
that um
the premise
um also and I I I suspect I could find
them I believe there was
um
press notes from the White House Press
Secretary that outlined the reason for
the um
the promulgation of these standards to
I see a hand up over here yes go ahead
thank you again Mr chair
I apologize I don't have the current RSA
that this repeals in front of me I'd
can you imagine
up a scenario where perhaps let's just
say there's a pandemic that
disproportionately let's just say
hypothetically speaking
disproportionately affects men more than
women and we've got scarce resources per
se and a doctor takes those scarce
resources and triages their patients and
says hey I want to give this to men not
women because men could very well die
and the women it's like it's like the
sniffles for them so so what they could
be doing is taking scarce resources and
saying I'm going to give it to the group
of people whether it's based on you know
sex or race or whatever that is you know
disproportionately affected by some
illness and I'm going to give it to them
even though there's others who are also
affected but they're not anywhere near
as affected so I don't know to me it
just seems like
I can imagine in my mind's eye that
there would be a time where it makes
sense to discriminate based on some of
these aspects and to have a blanket it
never ever under any circumstances could
actually lead to Greater death and
suffering have you thought about that
and if so what are your thoughts thank
you yes absolutely and it was wholly my
intent to craft a bill that would accept
those circumstances where it is the
medical evidence before you
um rather than
looking at it looking at an individual
rather than as a group Avatar
that the individual requires that
treatment regardless of whether it's
linked to sex or race or anything else
but they're receiving it because it's
appropriate care not because of their
yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
I'm I'm not really sure how to take your
testimony relative to uh the practice of
medicine in the state of New Hampshire
uh and I say that because my experience
is that we do not discriminate based on
any of the characteristics that you
described here and in fact
in general we have oftentimes very
limited resources to take care of a
large number of people
um as a result
Physicians Pas nurses every health care
provider needs to prioritize
where their time is spent and what
resources they use to take care of
patients
so my question is
in your case you mentioned about not
getting antiviral
perhaps it was because some of the
recommendations in medical you know
environment is if you don't have an
immunocompromised host if you're not
over the age of 65 if you're otherwise
healthy you don't get it and you get the
sniffles versus getting you know very
sick with some illness like coveted so
my question is rather than
have this I'm just trying to look for
specific examples that you may have
where
care that was appropriately prioritized
for individuals in the state was not
given to them that I would give you as a
problem but if people in healthcare were
providing prioritized resources in their
time for patients
based on good science evidence-based
science then that's not a problem so my
question is do you have the data
available that says there's a subset of
people that met the medical
qualifications for treatment in the
state of New Hampshire but were denied
it because of any of these reasons thank
you for your question I think I can
answer this question on three different
levels the first level will be anecdotal
in my particular case I do happen to be
immunocompromised and I have a
significant complicated health history
but I was nonetheless refused on the
next level would be the guidelines
promulgated from the federal government
for covid-19 vaccination early on when
this was still
when there truly were a limited resource
there was a significant subset of that
put aside just for certain populations
that was not
so it was basically the the whole of the
available vaccines were taken and broken
into two subsets one would be given out
based on
based on need and medical criteria the
other one was was really just
considering race
and there were civil rights complaints
filed in this state based on that and I
believe it led to the end of that
particular process the third way I would
answer that question is that this is a
newer phenomena it's not something
that's been going on for decades it's
really recently uh only in recent years
which brings me to the third handout I
gave you uh titled ideological
intensification which is a study put out
by the National Association of Scholars
which studies the incidence of these
particular terms such as equity
anti-racism and such and how they have
increased in an exponential manner in
academic literature in stem fields in
recent years
um so these these guidelines are newer
and they're being promulgated at a very
seeing none okay thank you thank you
no one else has signed up to testify
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 299.
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 299 and
open the house of the public hearing on
House Bill 614 and recognize the prime
foreign
good morning chairman McDonald Vice
chair Leon and honorable did you fill
out a pink card representative I did
it's good okay thank you very much sure
um my name is Nancy Murphy and I
represent Hillsborough County District
12 the town of Merrimack I'm happy to be
here again to reintroduce
this amendment was submitted to the
committee at the January 25th public
hearing on this bill
as background for this bill it's
important to know that Merrimack is the
site of the largest industrial
environmental disaster in the state's
history in 2016 our public drinking
water was discovered to have been
contaminated by pfoa which New Hampshire
Des attributed to air emissions from the
Sanko Bain performance plastic plant in
Merrimack it should be noted that in
addition to pfoa there were 190 other
pfests also found in Saint Cobain's air
emissions
my community has the dubious honor of
being referred to as New Hampshire's
Ground Zero for known widespread
long-term and ongoing pfas contamination
though scientific research has made us
aware of a number of negative human
health impacts known to be associated
with environmental exposure to these
toxic chemicals and though many of those
very same concerning Health outcomes are
self-reported by citizens
there have not been nor there currently
any comprehensive data collection
efforts in place to document and
investigate pfas Associated negative
Health outcomes amongst the 27 000
residents living in this contaminated
community
on January 13 2023 at the behest of
citizens and the HB 737 pfas Commission
DHHS presented an updated cancer
incident report which identified an
increase of excess cases of kidney
cancer in Merrimack
this trend up from 2018 is very
concerning to the people of Merrimack
and surrounding communities we are
paying out of pocket for well filtration
to protect our drinking water from the
dangers of pfas and many believe we are
also paying with our health
according to the National Institute of
Health's National Cancer Institute
division of cancer epidemiology and
genetics higher kidney cancer incidents
and mortality have been observed among
individuals with high P foa exposure
from employment and a pfest producing
chemical plant or residents in the
surrounding Community with contaminated
drinking water Merrimack is that
Community with contaminated drinking
water and now with more cases of kidney
cancer than would be expected
the DHHS cancer report stated that in
response to the increase in kidney
cancer cases the next appropriate step
would be to convey conduct an
investigation protocol phase 3
feasibility study just as it had
recommended the DHHS create a repository
for data collection relative to adverse
Health outcomes known to be associated
with pfas exposure
the pfas Visa the feasibility study we
are discussing today was also supported
and recommended for legislation and the
November 2022 HB 737 pfas commission
annual report to the governor HB 16 614
as amended has been brought forward
after significant collaboration with
DHHS and its Passage would provide the
department with resources necessary to
move forward with this important Health
investigation study this work has the
potential to benefit not only Merrimack
residents but all those living in New
Hampshire communities where
Environmental Testing has indicated the
presence of pfas
this study and a full epidemiological
study that might follow if determined to
be necessary could have positive impacts
on early detection cancer prevention and
better outcomes for pfas exposed
communities
the feasibility study relative to kidney
cancers as proposed in this amendment
is essentially foundational work for the
data collection sought for health
outcomes repository and can identify
appropriate cancers and health outcomes
for inclusion in a potential phase for
epidemiological study
so to wrap it up given the statistically
significant excess in the number of
cases of kidney cancer in Merrimack the
known exposure of this community to
environmental contaminants like pfas
that have been associated with kidney
cancer
an increase in the number of those
cancer diagnosis over time and the
recommendation of New Hampshire's DHHS
that a feasibility study as determined
by the New Hampshire cancer concern
investigation protocol phase three be
conducted to further investigate this
very concerning negative Health outcome
HB 614 is amended is meant to authorize
an appropriation to fund this cancer
investigation protocol as despite its
many phenomenal employees DHHS does not
have the expertise in-house no the
resources to complete the study on its
own
this work would be done through a
contract with an academic or research
organization and would inform next steps
in the investigation
this feasibility study would identify
appropriate Cancers and health outcomes
to be included in an epidemiological
study if that is determined to be
warranted as well as any other next
steps
additionally hb614 is amended will allow
DHHS to identify potential exposures
that may contribute to this excess of
kidney cancer incidence and Aid in
understanding how those exposures May
contribute to the excess of kidney
cancer cases in Merrimack
representatives from DHHS who are far
better equipped to answer specific
questions relative to the the
feasibility study are here to to do that
and provide any further information that
would be helpful
on behalf of a community greatly and
disproportionately negatively impacted
by a life-altering cancer diagnosis one
known to be associated with the pfas
contamination we have had long-term and
ongoing exposure to I ask that you
please vote OTP on HB 614 as amended
thank you for your time and attention
thank you questions representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for coming back for this
um
I think I'll ask some of my questions I
thought this was a study and not money
to design a study but do you know the
average amount of time that somebody
with with these kidney cancer cases has
lived in Merrimack versus those that
haven't and what that that time of
living in Merrimack is
thank you for the question I don't know
and I think that's part of of the
purpose of of the feasibility study I do
know just anecdotally that kidney cancer
has a very long latency period so we've
we've been probably exposed since the
1980s and sometimes it can be many 30
years you know it depends upon the
cancer and this is just one cancer
that's known to be Associated the only
one that's shown up and for the for the
New Hampshire cancer registry thank you
am I correct in understanding that the
purpose of the amendment
is to focus solely on a feasibility
study
at a much smaller expense than a
complete epidemiological study
so that we can determine whether the
larger expenditure is in fact
useful and helpful or unnecessary and
wasteful
yes thank you for your question exactly
um it the uh a phase four study is much
more extensive and much more expensive
and
um Federal funding is sometimes
available for those things but this part
has to be done first so it's a first
step and and it is the focus is smaller
based on the actual data that we have we
probably think there are a number of
health issues
um that we're experienced in the
community but this is the one we
yes representative thank you chairman
McDonald thank you for taking questions
I'd never heard of pfas before just like
a couple years ago
and now it seems like everybody's
talking about it is there any way that
we can I'm sure that New Hampshire would
not be the only state that would be
doing these kinds of studies is there
any way we could just save us a bunch of
money and piggyback off some other state
that does this or is there something
that's strictly specific for New
Hampshire information that we just can't
get from anywhere else thank you sure
thank you for the question
um I would probably defer to DHHS to
answer the specifics about the
feasibility study it's itself but I
would imagine that because it's specific
to a complete Community Based on the
exposure that we've had our community is
about 33 miles square miles I think and
the exposure is about 65 square miles so
we have had the the abundance of the
concentrated exposure through air our
water and our soil so I don't know if
another area in the country would have
similar exposures we we have more than
your average pfas exposure
any other questions
seeing none okay thank you thank you
oh excuse me can I ask a question
um representative Rosemary rung who was
the chair of the pfas commission
testified the last time but she's an
exact session and she gave me some
testimony she asked if I could read it
into the record or should I just hand it
submit it uh where she's not here could
you just distribute it to the members do
you have copies I don't have copies but
I'll get them okay okay thank you great
they also signed up to testify
several people from the health and human
services in the Department of Public
Health Services Michelle Roberts Whitney
good morning can you hear me okay I have
I have a cold so I'm going to keep my
mask on so
um just let me know if you are having a
hard time hearing me so good morning
members of the committee my name is
Michelle Roberts and I'm the
administrator of the Bureau of Public
Health protection within the Department
of Health and Human Services Division of
Public Health Services I have two of my
colleagues here with me today that will
be available to answer questions we have
Whitney Hammond who's the division's
chronic disease section administrator
and Dr Kathleen Bush who's the
environmental Public Health tracking
section administrator
the department is in support of the
proposed amendment to HB 614 which is
2023-0-111h
we are here as a resource to the
committee and happy to answer any
questions the committee may have
on January 13th Department presented the
cancer incident report for Merrimack New
Hampshire to the commission on the
environmental and public health impacts
of pfas substances commonly referred to
HB 737 Commission
the department serves on this commission
as a resource on potential Health
impacts from pfas exposures to the
communities represented by the
commission including Merrimack
this report is available on the
department's website and we are happy to
provide a copy to the committee as well
it is the position of the department
that the proposed amendment is more
aligned with the Department's
recommendations regarding next steps in
exploring potential exposures that could
have contributed to excess number of
kidney cancer cases observed in
Merrimack
the department has worked in
collaboration with representative Murphy
regarding the proposed amendment which
would provide necessary funds to support
the Department's recommendation to to
move to phase three in accordance with
the New Hampshire cancer concern
investigation protocol which does
include conducting a feasibility study
the feasibility study would be completed
through a contract with an academic or
research organization and would inform
next steps in the investigation
the goal of the feasibility study is to
gather additional information to help
determine what an epidemiological study
I'm sorry weather and epidemiological
study is warranted and would also
identify the appropriate Cancers and
health outcomes for inclusion in such a
study
the state cancer registry does not
include important information about
residential history
environmental exposures and kidney
cancer related risk factors such as
smoking a scientific literature review
which is one step in the feasibility
study would provide a better
understanding of the risk factors and
environmental exposures associated with
kidney cancer
in addition the study would identify
relevant data and determine the
plausibility that cases and contaminants
could potentially be Associated through
review of known contaminants and
potential exposure Pathways review of
historical records and Gathering of
residential occupational and exposure
histories
the study would also evaluate the
willingness and the ability of
identified cases to participate in this
data Gathering phase and would gather
input from community members about what
they need and want with regard to the
investigation and set expectations
around the process and potential
outcomes
the feasibility I'm sorry the
feasibility study would also include
developing a study hypothesis and
protocol obtain approval from an
Institutional review board to implement
the study analyze the data develop a
report and share the study results and
findings
the results of the feasibility study
will inform next steps in the
investigation including whether an
epidemiological or phase four for study
is warranted and if such study could be
funded
the proposed 500 000 appropriation to be
provided to the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services would
support this study
thank you for your time today and we
would be happy to answer any questions
that you may have
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
being here this is definitely a
complicated topic and I'm so glad to
have your expertise if I could ask a
couple questions within there the first
is regarding the funding have you
pursued any federal grants or looking at
the possibility of one of these
institutions charging a post-doc with
this in order to look into this in order
to build their own research as part of
their current academic path as opposed
to a taxpayer expense
and yes I'll follow up after that
no we have not uh pursued any federal
funding for this um this was a
representative uh Murphy came to us and
talked about sort of next steps so
that's sort of where we are we just
delivered uh the report on January 13th
and I would add in so we do work closely
uh The Entity that actually operates our
New Hampshire cancer registry is
Dartmouth and we do have a close
relationship with them in terms of you
know trying to explore opportunities to
collaborate on Federal grant
applications the feedback typically from
them has been that they need what they
call preliminary data or the data that
we're going to collect through or that
is proposed to be collected through this
feasibility study to actually submit a
fundable application for research
thank you um and for follow-up
um it sounded like there was no
residency information was there any
information collected on how long these
people that have these incidents of
kidney cancer have lived in Merrimack or
is that just that they're currently a
resident of Merrimack so the cancer
registry we follow the guidelines that
CDC gives us in terms of the data and
how it's collected and that is done
um in so it's based on the time at
diagnosis so that we don't get any
residential history and in fact people
could live elsewhere when they're
diagnosed and we wouldn't we wouldn't
get that information either so it's only
the time it diagnosis with kidney cancer
that's captured
okay and then as my last follow-up do
you expect that this will be completed
within two years or will this need to go
into the following biennial budget
I would expect it could be completed
within two years
thank you
yes representative Cannon
along the same line uh question have you
approached unh
that's an organization that might be
interested in in doing a lot of this
work
so I've served on the hb7 37 since its
Inception and one of the members of that
commission is Amy Costello from UNH
Institute of Health policy and practice
so they too are an active member in this
area of research but I think they would
share similar sentiments to Dartmouth
that preliminary data is really
necessary in order to write a
see no other questions representative
land thank you for letting me triple dip
here my other question is what kind of
actual study do you intend to fund
within this is there actually going to
be a collection of data or is this just
designing a study in order to put in
that Grant application either to the
state or to another body
so this would involve designing a study
to collect additional data from
individuals who and again the case
definition would be part of what this
entity would figure out but it would be
at least inclusive of people who were
residents in Merrimack at the time they
were diagnosed with kidney cancer and
the data Gathering that would be funded
through this would include information
about things like residential history
things like once the literature review
was complete and we had an understanding
of all the different known risk factors
for kidney cancer we would be capturing
that sort of you know information as
well so things like smoking history and
then that all would ultimately be used
to develop some kind of a potential
study hypothesis and you know inform a
sorry and my one last question is do you
expect that this will be designed so
that there may be a signal that says
that there's no information here to be
found and we've terminated this at this
point without going on to phase four
yes I think there's the potential for
that
is that defined
can you say that again is that defined
within the program or just a a
possibility
sorry I'll follow it the protocol allows
for that to be a decision at the end of
phase three of a feasibility study that
we may not be able to gather enough data
to detect a statistically significant
relationship but I would like to make
the point that that doesn't mean that
there's not risk factors in the region
that may be contributing to excess
kidney cancer simply because we can't
detect a signal
um I hope that answers your question it
does thank you
yes representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and taking my question
um I'm wondering how familiar your
department is with uh the Biden
administration's plan that was recently
launched to combat pfas pollution and to
study the problem I'm seeing 15 million
dollars being put into this program and
is this premature in doing this
feasibility study until that program has
been implemented and releases some
conclusions and we know the scope of it
and how it's going to be enacted in the
state
I would say that the scientific field of
pfas and health effects is an evolving
field and so the work done here in
Merrimack will contribute to any
national work being done I don't think
it's premature to do this and we work
closely with Partners at CDC and atsdr
probably the entities who would be
pursuing this work under the Biden
Administration so I think that this work
would be collaborative and supportive of
any other National initiatives
thank you
um I would actually add in that part of
the goal of this phase is to come up
with a study hypothesis and again
knowing that kidney cancer has other
known risk factors we're not necessarily
at a place where we are testing a
hypothesis between pfas and kidney
cancer so this might actually set us up
to be in a better place when funding
specific to pfas becomes available from
okay
seeing no other questions
Nick signed up to speak is Dr Michael
Leon
Tom thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee full disclosure I am related
by marriage to uh the vice chairman of
this committee so you've probably
already told you you have three minutes
right yes I usually have less at home
um
so briefly
um my background I'm 52 I've been
involved with biomedical research since
I've been 17 years old I've focused most
of my life on oncology or cancer
research solid cancer including kidney
cancer as well as benign and malignant
hematology
I had the honor of doing my training at
doctoral training at Dartmouth since
then I've worked for companies both
large and small I've been involved in
biomedical research from very rare
diseases where the number of subjects is
under 100 significantly under 100 to
those in the several thousand
in designing a study
the thought of five hundred thousand
dollar price tag if this happened in
industry
there better be an Ethics investigation
by the office of the Inspector General
this is absolutely an absurd amount of
money to design a study not to conduct a
study one of the more recent studies
that I designed at the NIH is actually
funding the total cost for operating the
study was a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars there are studies that cost
millions of dollars that is true but to
go on a fishing expedition in a very
very small focused area with the
assumption that you're going to find
something related to pfas and kidney
cancer you need to look at the state
data there's less than 300 cases on
average in New Hampshire of kidney
cancer we are below the national average
we are increasing ever so slightly
if you look at Merrimack yes one year
it's spiked up to attribute that to pfas
you need to have solid data over several
years The Five-Year moving average is
not showing that in fact only two
counties neither of which are mentioned
are increasing in New Hampshire
I highly encourage this study to be
pursued this can be done by Academia to
pursue either registry or come up with a
study design and come back and there are
certainly funding if one looks on the
CDC website today the NIH to fund such a
study
thank you
seeing no questions
and the final person who has signed up
to speak
and hopefully I get the name right uh
Christopher bandazian uh the chairman of
the legislative study committee on
environmental and health effects of pfas
how'd I do with the name
oh wow
okay
push the button for the microphone
please
committee better better thank you all
um
my perspective is somewhat unique but
I've been a member of the HB 737
commission for the last three years and
I'm the new chair and I've been the
chair of the environmental subcommittee
for all three years that we have issued
reports and I do thank representative
Murphy and the other sponsors of this
bill for bringing this matter forward
my own involvement began long before the
HB 737 commission is a member of a
governing body in the neighboring town
of Bedford that is served by part of it
served by MVD Wells that had a high
level of contamination for the area of
Bedford that is served by MVD as well as
the Upland area of Merrimack that being
Wells four and five that were taken
offline uh very quickly in 2016 but at
that time those Wells had a very high
level
of pfas contamination and probably did
for a very long period into into the
past and so Merrimack which is
predominantly served by uh public water
presents a very good opportunity for
academic study and research and the
ultimate goal not to lose sight of it is
proper screening of patients early
identification of potential cancers And
Timely treatment of patients and that
benefits Public Health not just in
Merrimack but all over the state where
pfas contamination sites exist from near
the Canadian border in Pittsburgh down
to Swansea and all the way out to
Hampton so it's a problem that exists
across the state there is probably no
better system to study than the
Merrimack system because of that local
contamination and concentration in Wells
four and five
with those Wells being brought offline
in 2016
um
population as you know disperses and uh
other risk factors intrude and so as
time goes by the quality of data
degrades and
um this is something that is a timely
piece of research and it should be
pursued in my opinion as well as the
opinions of my colleagues on the HB 737
commission as I stated earlier this
journey became began a long time ago
when it came to light to the public in
2016. the governor in August of 2018
convened a round table
meeting with agency Commissioners and
agency staff as well as people like
myself who are representing the
governing bodies of the affected towns
um I was very pleased to learn at that
time that state epidemiologist Dr Chan
had requested a health consultation from
the CDC already in June of 2016. so only
four months after this came to light and
so uh and I quickly received an
education on some of some of the issues
that have been raised here which is why
can't this be done from an academic
research institution with NIH funding
perhaps and that goes back to my roots
in a different occupation at a different
time but I quickly learned about the
limitations that are available
in terms of getting research done in the
state of New Hampshire
that phase two I was completed and I
apologize if I'm taking up too much time
uh
if you could start wrapping up please
okay uh phase two that was presented by
DHHS staff uh to the Commission in
January I would say was a very
um well-conceived well-executed
well-presented study we are very well
served by our DHHS staff and scientists
I feel privileged and proud to work with
them every single month that the
commission has been in session in the
people of New Hampshire should be as
well
this is the next bridge to the ultimate
objective of being able to screen
residents of New Hampshire properly
early diagnosed cancers or rule out
concerns that should be ruled out and
ultimately with the objective of
improving public health and reducing
mortality so the commissioner fully
supports this effort and would ask for
any questions I see no questions okay
I have no other uh I have no one else
signed up to testify does anyone wish to
testify on this amendment
um
2023 hyphen zero one one-h to uh house
I'm seeing no one uh wanting to testify
this gentleman's approaching and you
don't want to testify right
okay
oh all right okay fine uh thank you
um okay I'm going to close the public
2023-011h-111h on hb614
um I'm going to close that public
hearing and we have no public hearing
scheduled at this point until 1 pm so we
yes
we can talk yes perfect no reason to
good afternoon everyone
I'm calling the meeting back to order
um of the health and human services and
elderly Affairs committee we have a
hearing
um
pending here on House Bill 223 excuse me
and um we have the prime sponsor here
representative Mark Pearson somebody we
have seen once or twice already today
well yeah that's you Mr representative
first of all my new best friend Mr Cousy
and I uh had a conversation as you know
and so here is a new amendment to
um 322 which we discussed this morning
if I may if you make it sure go ahead uh
if you have the old amendments
that's not the one we want
so we keep the nurses we add the
physician's assistant and I hope
everybody's happy I know that I'm
the pain in the ass but uh we can't
discuss 322 right now you can pass it
out but we can't discuss it oh I did I'm
sorry yeah you're not a pain in the
aforementioned
but anyway yeah no I I'm assuming you're
just going to testify on 323 right and
that is what I'm doing and I apologize
in advance that this is only one page
long
late uh last term the late and much
beloved representative Catherine Rogers
submitted proposed legislation under
Bill number HB 1290 entitled
establishing a task force on Precision
medicine and biomarker testing it was
assigned to this committee then
Committee Member Dr Jeffrey soloway
suggested we vote the bill interim study
and that the chairman of DHHS oversight
would appoint a special subcommittee to
work on the bill immediately this
committee voted interim study 20-0 and I
as chairman of oversight appointed
representative Solway as chairman of
that special subcommittee the
subcommittee made its report back to
oversight and several of us prepared the
bill that you have before us the concern
regarding emerging medical Technologies
is twofold first the state must assess
its role in facilitating new
preventative and Curative Technologies
secondly the state must provide
oversight to determine where something
new may prove to be harmful
this bill establishes a committee to
keep abreast of such emerging
Technologies and facilitate them when
warranted and sound an alarm when
necessary you will notice not
surprisingly the language similar to the
bill on the Board of Medicine which I
will not discuss you heard in committee
this morning specifically in these ways
naming of alternative members who can
step in when needed during hearings
while their presence we hope at every
meeting will augment the wisdom of the
regular members their absence will not
work against the necessary quota for
voting
secondly because of a Bill signed into
law last year mandating a majority of
voting members of a study committee be
legislators yet acknowledging how
important the regular presence of
stakeholders is to the work of the
committee provision is made in the bill
to ask various organizations to send
individuals as regular participants and
not the occasional Observers three there
is a sunset provision of October 1st
2028 with the house now having a special
committee on committees perhaps to weed
out unnecessary and dormant ones Sunset
Provisions may be wise and they are
becoming increasingly popular if a
committee has done its work it needs to
disappear if not it can be reauthorized
these three items may become the new
normal in crafting bills establishing
committees and I end by saying thank you
to representative Rogers first of all
for her life work here but secondly on
this specific issue and thank you to
representative soloway for walking this
through a subcommittee to write the bill
okay thank you questions
representative Pearson
yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Pearson for taking my
question so
um the this new committee
is is its intention to be studying
emerging medical Technologies and and to
do what with that information exactly
to
be in regular touch with Scientists with
medical leaders in the state
this will be a a forum whereby those
people can be brought together to study
what is considered emerging medical
Technologies and then to make
so would part of the purpose of this
committee be to recommend any enabling
legislation that might be necessary
in light of emerging Technologies
that don't
necessarily fit into our current
regulatory scheme to make sure that we
are keeping abreast just as we have done
for example in the issue of Telehealth
that new technologies are not only being
used appropriately being promoted
appropriately when whence that's due
I would say yes that is correct this is
not to say that any medical schools in
New England aren't doing this or any
other groups aren't doing this this just
makes sure that there is a group
in part of legislators so that that
connection between science and
legislation will be in place
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Pearson for taking my
question
historically
legislative bodies have a tendency to be
reactionary
and we try to catch up with what's going
on in the market
I see this bill as a way to be more
proactive
to have people coming to the legislative
body
to follow representative Weber said to
be able to enable legislation to take
care of what's emerging is that a fair
statement or should I say would you
believe well I was ready to say I do
believe that even before that but yeah
that is a fair statement thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Pearson
um I have a little bit of past
experience in this area I'm curious if
you would be looking for this commission
to this committee to look early in the
pre-clinical development when it's
starting to move out of the lab into
human when it's moving around to after
the FDA approval process after that
prior to reimbursement or after the
reimbursement scheme is there I know
there's a large spectrum and I'm curious
where the focus would be it will be
curious to see how it plays out as they
come together what they see their
initial focus and the number of focal
points would become
representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative
Pearson
um
I'm struck by
something I tried to understand better
last night specifically what was the
definition of an emerging technology and
the reason why I asked the question has
to do with um
line 21 of the bill when it talks
examining the barriers the reason why I
was thinking this is we heard about
naturopathy earlier today
I can think of a lot of very old
modalities that are frankly totally
lacking at evidence-based that over time
we're seeing evidence-based develop that
may say that yes there is uses that are
reasonable and should be paid for
whatever
do you see this at all in looking at Old
modalities that don't have evidence that
now do or constantly re-examining the
evidence based on those things once
again I think the scope will be
determined by the group that's put
together while the initial
attention was given to new things I
would not necessarily say that this new
group would not look at old things that
perhaps have not gained wider acceptance
but I'll leave that to them
okay
yeah it's it's an unrelated question
am I okay to ask it okay
um
I'm curious also we're fortunate to have
an expert on stem cell therapies here
um stem cell therapies
um have potential Great Value they also
have a fair amount of charlatanism too
do you see this group as a way of
consumer advocacy protecting people from
the Charlton charlatanism aspect of
those things
this is a question that came up
yesterday at children and family law in
a different way
there's a lot of people out there
there's a lot of gurus with gimmicks
as well as Dr snow at the pump handle in
SoHo who alone
found out where cholera came from so
just because it's new just because it's
unpopular doesn't mean it's wrong but
just because it's new and it's in the
news doesn't mean it's right I would say
that yes I hope that there would be a
judicious cautioning to the public of
something that is gaining some traction
other questions
yes
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you for taking my question
um I was just wondering as I was reading
this I'm thinking
should a bill like this in a committee
of this nature which is obviously look
into the future for a lot of stuff
should we even Sundown it in the first
place should we what Sundown and should
we uh repeal it
um October of 28. I'm just I was
thinking that
just we will have emerging Technologies
going forward indefinitely in
um do we need to repeal it or would we
want to just basically leave it
open-ended I didn't write the bill but I
can sniff the wind and right now there's
a kill attitude towards lots of
commissions that have not met so to
placate anyone and each and several uh
when this language was given to me
um I didn't try to strike it out if it's
doing a good job it can be re-upped
yeah I would agree with that I was just
the previous ones that we did sun down I
understood because they have a time
limit to it to me my opinion would be
that this may be an ongoing you know
evolutionary type of committee as time
goes by it was mostly a thought not a
criticism of the bill obviously well in
2018 2028 for my position as chairman of
Fish and Game I may be back to ask for a
re-up
representative land
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um I'm looking at the um basically the
advisory members of this the there all
seem to be appointed members of the
medical society pharmacists Association
um Etc and I'm sure there will be you
know general public uh opportunity for
the general public to come and speak but
um I'm just concerned if we're we're
kind of looking at
um
you know how do I say this okay
um concern that all of these
organizations are kind of gonna have a
similar Viewpoint and maybe just the
um a registered nurse period or a
registered nurse not a member of the New
Hampshire Nurses Association you see
what I'm saying like it would be nice to
get a Viewpoint from a professional who
may not be a part of these professional
organizations and therefore may have a
different
understanding of what is coming out
I would agree and given what we passed
and the governor signed Last Summer
the only members are the legislative
members and these others are people we
would really like to see on a regular
basis I saw that language as inclusive
not exclusive that if anybody wants to
show up including but not limited to
physician assistance they have a right
to send somebody and a nurse who is not
appointed by the nursing association can
show up what I would encourage is
regularity if you're going to be part of
the process we need they they I'm not
going to be on this but they would need
to see such a person or such persons
regularly so
I would like to see the lone voice
crying Against The Establishment if that
person comes prepared and comes
regularly
um what would your opinion be to include
some of the
um patient advocacy organizations in New
Hampshire like Health Freedom New
Hampshire uh and appointee from their
organization as well if the committee
concludes that broadening the list of
those specified to be invited
um fine I do not believe that the author
of the bill
um
and I certainly don't believe myself
this would be a bad thing
um Bring It On thank you
representative Cannon
thank you Mr chair
if I remember correctly we we uncovered
that there were numerous conferences on
this topic all by itself as far as the
variety of medical opportunities there
were and I and I
and I think that's where a lot of we
uncovered the number of people that we
would include would would be from
different perspectives that might have
some input from those conferences and
information is that correct
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair
and thank you again representative
Pearson for taking the question
in I do concur with what representative
Murphy was saying in regards to
sunsetting this
instead of it being decided by the
legislative body since it's part of the
oversight Committee of DHHS
with the appropriate place to make the
determination whether to extend it or
not
be there in a legislative body
can't do it that way
I would be happy however this came into
being and if this committee wishes to
send it over to oversight again that's
where this it started here went over to
oversight has come back here and if we
want to do this for a while we can do
that and I wouldn't mind overseeing it
since I'd share that body
it's up to you folks wherever it best
lands is good with me
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Pearson we've spoken to some of the
opportunities but you also spoke to
identifying risk when I was on Wall
Street we dealt with the late strength
thrombosis people were getting blood
clots after they got this great new
technology and it wasn't saving lives
what do how do you see the role of this
committee evaluating new emerging
threats possibly ahead of the FDA and do
you think that this would have any role
in people's concerns over the coveted
vaccine and potential harm and increased
various cases
I hope that they would follow the
research that is being done various
places follow the literature but also to
the degree that they are able and
willing to do it Blaze the trail
themselves
so I would like them to be part of the
process but perhaps on some occasions
even lead the process
thank you and just if I can have one
other follow-up with my experience I
worked with some of the cell and tissue
regeneration that was just in in
Academia before and now is in Manchester
at army I was curious because that is
truly emerging Technologies and growing
organs I was wondering if that has any
it would be impossible to ask
representative Rogers that question but
those of you who know her very well may
have had a conversation with her about
this this bill was presented I remember
when she did it before us and I don't
remember that maybe some of you who were
there might so I don't know it's
expanded greatly since then yeah that
was that was biomarkers so there's been
no conversation with army about the
benefits for that
not to my knowledge thank you but
remember I'm the liberal arts kid I
don't know these things
seeing no other questions
and Mr chairman if I may I have my
one-page testimony sure everyone sure
I have no other people oh okay
apparently we have another pink card
foreign
welcome back
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um it's a privilege to sit up
here again I think this bill is
incredibly well intentioned
I am uh scratching my head trying to
figure out what this body actually
thinks they're going to accomplish with
this bill
um of all the companies I've worked for
I worked for one of the largest
biotechnology companies and I learned
two things when I was there I was told
by the head of a very large department
at MGH I'm not going to throw his name
out
the company I work for was a great legal
organization with a small biotech
attached to it
the biggest office this company had
which I think everyone here would
recognize was in Washington D.C
when I saw the amount of money that the
company spends on lobbying not only in
DC but in each and every state level
ahead of approvals my head spun
how this body is going to stay up on
emerging medical Technologies baffles me
as a member of the American Society of
hematology the American Society of
clinical oncology and the American
Association of cancer research I spent
about a week at each of those
organizations every year trying to keep
up on just that narrow focus of those
areas
and when you go to that there's 20 000
people at each of those you don't keep
up on the entire field if you go ask
hematologists go to Dartmouth go down to
MGH go to the Farber they have
Specialists who specialize in one
disease they spend all day looking into
the newest Technologies companies are
lining up to see these people how are
you going to stay on top of emerging
Technologies and if you do do they
present equal risks to the people of New
Hampshire that is if people see take
smoking for example that used to be
recommended by physicians to pregnant
women to relax them we know that that's
not a good thing we know that it leads
to several types of cancer including
kidney cancer which we just chatted
about
I've seen people walking into this
building at outside the building smoking
cigarettes today do they not know
they're
whatever information this body could
make people aware of they were aware of
and most unfortunately the late
honorable representative Rogers was well
aware of two biomarkers she had that
directly led to her death that she was
aware of in 2012. I told her in
committee
I'm not sure what you're hoping to
accomplish there are a lot of people out
there working on emerging Technologies
less than 10 percent that get into
humans actually make it to Market and
long before they get to Market I
guarantee you companies are spending a
lot of money to send lobbyists to come
find all of you
without question and with that I'd be
happy to take questions
I'm not seeing any
oh I'm sorry yes
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
other are there other states that that
have bodies like this and do you know
what kind of output they've had
with respect to Pharma companies and
biotech I have not had that such
encounters at all I believe most
companies hire lobbyists specifically at
the state level and at the federal level
they have both lobbyists and Incredibly
large law offices
thank you thank you representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking this question is your is your
concern specifically that we are
creating a target for lobbyists not not
at all I I think you're taking on far
too big a uh bite if you will
to be able to stay where are you going
to focus is it going to be on cancer is
it going to be on inflammation the two
are actually related it you know it
Endocrinology is it going to be surgery
is it going to be medical devices and
medical devices how many different
subtypes are there
follow up so and in regard to the your
comments about lobbyists
I I I'm assuming that you're thinking
that those lobbyists will come whether
there's this kind of committee or not a
hundred a hundred percent and I think
probably the most relevant one that
would be very easy for anyone to spend
30 seconds online and find is
immunotherapy and cancer
when the therapies first came out I have
an aunt whose life was extended by seven
years she was diagnosed within three
weeks of approval of the first
immunotherapy drug approved
they come with horrible side effects
companies were doing everything they
could to get in front of every
legislative body every reimbursement
organization they could ahead of this
not to mention trying to educate
Physicians nurses pharmacists Etc what
needed to happen to make these drugs
available to patients along with the
potential risks which included death and
long-term sequelae of how to manage them
so I I think this is very well
intentioned I think it's uh it's too big
a bite for for any single body to bite
off
thank you
thank you representative Palmer
so but in a way you're arguing for this
bill because
otherwise this people in the state and
legislators are going to hear primarily
from the lobbyists and not from a body
that's maybe been able to do some
research as an individual I'll never be
able to keep up this committee at least
would have a shot at keeping up is that
not true
when I left graduate school at Dartmouth
in 2004 there was an article in Journal
of American Medical Association if a
physician and his or her specialty read
two papers a day by the end of the year
they'd be several hundred papers behind
it's it's very Noble to try and take
this on where you're going to focus how
are you going to know this and things
that get propelled from phase one that
go to a registration study right there's
phase one two and three these can take
several years there are some that are so
overwhelmingly convincing they get
incredibly accelerated are you going to
miss those will you pick them all up
I I think it's a very big bite that the
uh Noble but a very big bike the
representative King
thank you Mr chair
um
so this doesn't have any FN to it
doesn't it's not going to cost taxpayers
anything and
um
everybody who would be a member of this
committee my understanding is that it
would be volunteer based right so
nobody's being forced to join this
committee and it does seem like yes it
could be a big waste of time on their
part but that's a big cost if they want
to do that well but that's if they want
to do that so I'm just curious what do
you think is the worst case scenario
this committee gets you know built
what's the worst thing that could happen
from it other than a bunch of people get
together and they just waste their time
that's I think that's probably the worst
that's going to happen and you have a
lot of important work to do
and have been doing a lot of important
work
is this body going to produce something
of value for the people of New Hampshire
for the residents of New Hampshire with
representative Nagel
hi oh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um I'm just curious because I totally
understand what you're saying
um I
um I'm just curious though would there
be any value in this being react and I'm
going to get back to the stem cell thing
again
any value that's being reactive as
opposed to proactive because proactive
seems to me to be Beyond Comprehension
whereas reactive there's issues that the
state faces on a regular basis that it
would be helpful to have a bunch of
experts
100 100 on that if you're then you could
look at specific cases
um and if I can go out on a Ledge I've
worked with representative Merchant
before with one company I used to work
with the biggest line items for CMS that
literally the biggest line item for CMS
um unfortunately in retrospect I think
there was a lot of commercial influence
that that emanated from at least a
couple companies that pushed out
it still benefited some patients to have
a body be able to focus just on those
particular drugs where they can be used
um
I think there could absolutely be value
in that and especially when there are
drugs that exist out right now that may
have been purposed for one disease and I
think this was brought up brought up by
a representative Pearson in his
testimony if you have a
drug that has been used for one disease
and may be repurposed in another disease
and I'm trying to think of something I
haven't touched
smallpox vaccine or
that was almost instantly repurposed
with high efficacy for monkeypox
that's
would be terrific for this committee to
be able to put together ad hoc a small
committee and focus on just that maybe
there's something else that's coming out
and I think with the number of
healthcare providers on this committee
with Healthcare experience you would
probably stay much more abreast of
not up and coming Technologies but
technologies that are either already
approved or so incredibly close to
approval you know they've been on the
news
thank you for the question that's
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
with the committee being there part of
it what I would say is
it allows the community to hear emerging
Technologies in the barriers that we
have legislatively
versus trying to figure out which one's
to support but trying to understand from
the industry what's emerging and what we
can do to try to Foster it to understand
it with the scientists involved
that's kind of where I see it headed
versus trying to look at the whole Apple
like you said it's a huge Universe out
there but I would turn around say would
you be okay with the people coming to
this committee saying these are concerns
we have legislatively that are barriers
to us bringing this technology to Market
so I think being able to work with
companies who are the ones developing
drugs that could absolutely work
especially if the committee were to set
the interface not as a lobbyist who's
paid but you have a medical director you
have a global development the people who
are in charge of development that from
the scientists who who is either
intimately familiar with the pathway the
medical technology Etc the people most
closely associated with it and on the
commercial side how how do you pay for
it what are what are going to be the
barriers and as far as nurses how do you
navigate
patient a walks in the door
what's going to change from standard
medical practice
what can the state do to support that by
all means
I did want to make a comment I want to
say thank you spending the time which
I'm trying to get to you help educate me
on many things and I think it was that
education which has helped me within the
medical center to try to understand how
to make it work within the medical
center so I want to say thank you
thank you kindly other questions
seeing any other questions
also signed up to testify is
representative Jess Edwards who's a
uh thank you Mr chair and the committee
um I'm representative Jess Edwards
representing uh Rock Rockingham District
31. uh I didn't intend to speak today uh
but I I thought some of what I might
have to say could be useful to you as
you decide how you want to dispose of
this bill uh I yeah I'm recommending
OTP uh I I think much of the concerns uh
and opportunities have been sort of
suggested by committee members but I I
just want to
excuse me uh drive into a couple
specific points on page two line 15 the
committee shall well the committee shall
if you start to read those bullets it's
basically about having the legislature
improve awareness understanding and uh
and uh and understand emerging medical
Technologies initially where this all
got its momentum was in the biomarker
bill and as we started to try to figure
out what to do with the biomarker bill
we realized that you know that issue
wasn't right but that the field of
emerging medical technology is extremely
expansive and going in all directions
personally my background in this area
has been in positron a mission
tomography co-registration a functional
and structural Imaging the medical
imaging in general telemedicine so those
were all at one point emerging medical
technologies that I think have become
ripe in one way or another for some
legislative action this committee would
be established so that there would be a
mechanism for the legislature to have
better awareness of those Trends we're
not we're not driving the train you know
basically I think our job is to as a
legislature is to lead follow or get the
heck out of the way and what this
committee would do would be sort of an
indication to us on what is the
appropriate role of the legislator
legislature like for example on line 21
are there barriers that should be
examined to see if the if somehow we've
got some archaic legislative structure
that maybe needs to be addressed
you know when when the Army money uh
came to us for the regenerative
I don't know body parts whatever
um
there weren't a lot of people in the
house that understood that issue to
begin with so we ended up helping
by providing tax breaks or subsidies
that were significant so we do get
involved in emergency emerging medical
Technologies from time to time hopefully
this go this committee would would help
us with that sort of awareness before
somebody asks us to write a check
also we get involved with the payer
decision making Medicaid specifically
spends a lot of money and there's a
there was a bill to require that all
telemedicine be reimbursed at a rate
equal to the clinical inpatient rate
that was a legislative decision on
evaluating emerging medical technology
in its current state and in its future
state so we end up getting called into
making these decisions and I and I I
don't know if we have any organized
structure to help us be smart in in that
area uh there's a patient privacy aspect
to this in all emerging technology we
got to worry about uh potential effects
of privacy there there's there's not a
whole lot of bad that can happen with
this committee
um we've got a major filter these guys
this committee goes and reports through
HHS oversight to propose legislation HHS
oversight which in itself is not a
really a standing policy committee so so
it's not like we're building a highly
responsive uh system
we say it should only meet once a year
well why do we say that we say that it
can meet more frequently should there be
a need but once a year yes sir we would
we would take a survey of what's taking
place for for General situational
awareness and and disband and if this
turns out to be a feckless Board of
human beings it sunsets itself in just a
few years you know so to your to your
question why is there a sunset well
because this is a this is a grand
experiment and if it if if it's a waste
then it shuts itself down if it's not
then we can keep it going but uh so so
so I think I think that should help with
a little bit of perspective on why this
is proposed you know what if you think
it's a good idea or not it's totally up
to you I think it's a it's an okay idea
thank you representative Edwards
questions for representative Edwards
thank you none thank you very much
representative King
thank you thank you chairman McDonald
thank you representative Edwards
um I see government oversight more like
the eye of Zaron and when it finds
something it generally tends to destroy
the good as opposed to get get things
that are bad out of the way and I like
your testimony that it could potentially
find barriers to
um something that is needed but there's
maybe a government barrier that they can
get out of the way
um but is that realistic I mean do you
really see that a government committee
is going to look for ways to get the
government out of the way that that's
like totally antithetical to what like
most government is I just it seems to me
like the government and people that are
staffed in it they want to create more
laws and they oftentimes kill the baby
in the crib so that's my concern
so I share your deep cynicism but not
your not your choice of fan fiction so
but I think I can understand where
you're going with that
um I uh I I think we built this in a way
in which it can't really do a lot of
harm even if the if they wanted to
um so uh and I would point out that uh
the legislature has in fact played a
very significant policy role in uh
furthering the acceptance of
telemedicine in New Hampshire uh it was
not more than six years ago where the
commercial carriers were reimbursing for
telemedicine and Medicaid really was not
and so we as a policy decision I think
it went through HHS made the
determination that Medicaid would get in
the game and follow the lead of
commercial carriers so that telemedicine
could become more accepted we did that
at a policy level saying okay if if we
get more consistency amongst the payers
the providers will then think okay this
is a reimbursable service I'm going to
go ahead and invest in this emerging
technology and so so
I would never underestimate the ability
of government to do damage but we do
have a track record of doing some good
things in New Hampshire as well
I have no one else signed up to speak on
this bill
has anyone else wish to speak on House
Bill 323
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 323
we have noticed to go into executive
session at 1 30. it is now past 1 30. so
I am going to begin and open the
executive session
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
note the presence of two substitute
members so representative page is here
for representative Tellez and
representative naughter or
representative colfault thank you and
welcome both and and could I also
apologize to the people who were sitting
in front of the windows I opened at
lunchtime and thank you for shouting
them again actually the one that's still
open but it uh I don't feels kind of
good in here so
much better than it did last Friday
I would have last Friday yes what's that
does anyone want the window shot or
everybody comfortable
I guess everybody's comfortable but
thank you
okay again we are now in executive
session
and the um we dealt with uh House Bill
91- FNA last week so the first bill for
us to consider today is HP 587 FN and
I'd recognize representative McLean for
a motion
thank you Mr chair I would make a motion
to retain the bill
representative let me just read the
blurb about what bill it is not just the
number okay I'm sorry uh and I'm sorry I
had to answer relative to a New
Hampshire first designation on the donor
registry for anatomical gifts
is that is that enough representative or
okay
okay is there a second to um
representative McLean's motion
representative lay on seconds
I'm sorry representative McKay seconded
discussion
representative uh McLean would you like
to speak to your motion uh yes uh thank
you Mr chair
um I think that the the management of of
organs for donation is something that is
done at the federal level so I don't
know that this
um legislation would would do anything
uh relative to to the issues that the
sponsors brought forward
um and also I don't know that we have a
an understanding of the relative flow of
organs into the state and out of the
state so I I really think that we should
wait and get more data so that we might
understand better how this might impact
you know uh the the transmission of
organs in an organ donation thank you Mr
chair thank you representative McLean
any other discussion
yes representative Weber
I would say that my my first thought on
this bill was to an expedient to
legislate for any number of reasons that
we heard but I have to say that in light
of the very conflicting testimony that
we heard
um if it's the pleasure of the committee
to retain
I don't I don't see that as a problem
but I would love to hear from other
people about their thoughts sure
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um personally I was very moved by the
two people who came to testify who said
they had both received
um
a heart and were here 10 years later and
20 years later one with a little baby
and I was and I was very moved by their
testimony that had have if New Hampshire
passes legislation like this and other
states respond by passing similar
legislation
that they might not have had those
organs available to them so I came set
to vote for itl at the same time I was
very moved by a couple of legislators
one who I've known while they've gone
through the process of getting a new
kidney and how impassioned they were
about the bill so I would be very
amenable to voting to retain the bill
and thinking about it more and hearing
more about it later on
thank you anyone else wish to speak any
all right seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the wall
again the motion is to retain on House
all right I have a little housekeeping
to do first uh it's representative page
and you're
it's just not earth
we have representative Nutter and
goes with the Kings
okay
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Nutter yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative mazur yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov yes
representative Weber
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative page
yes
there's 20 to zero
and not until I vote oh sorry the common
mistake I've been a clerk too
representative McDonald's yes
I used to do that to Barbara Griffin on
the redistricting committee who's
the vote is 20-0 to retain House Bill
um we also dealt with House Bill 47 last
week which was relative to medical
um
yes we did yes so next up for our
consideration today is the house bill
and
do I have a motion representative
Merchant would you like to make a motion
yes I'll make a motion OTP okay is there
a second to that motion
that representative Leon representative
Merchant would you like to speak to your
motion
yes thank you Mr chair
it's a simple bill in a sense that we
learn that
one of the
drugs under the Control prescription act
if you will
is rarely abused as far as being used
topically for testosterone in this bill
basically provides a patient the
opportunity to have it filled four times
a year versus 12 times a year it doesn't
stop the use of the drug based upon the
need for the patient and basically at
this point in time as it said in a bill
before there's two parts to it one is
abuse and the other one's corresponding
responsibility by having the provider or
the prescriber right on the prescription
the medical need for it it helps
alleviate the concern that the
pharmacist may have in violation of
corresponding responsibility with the
DEA so therefore I support the bill
okay the discussion
I suppose sorry I support the bill
because many other prescriptions can be
done on a quarterly basis this is just
giving an exemption to the controlled
Drug Act and uh when you look at the
dose dose makes the poison and dose also
makes it whether or not it's it's
something that can reasonably be abused
or not and I don't imagine anybody
swimming in tubes of uh these topical
representative Nagel I support the bill
as well um and my only thought that we
had talked about that I wanted to
re-emphasize is that it perhaps at some
point it may be helpful to go through
all the schedule three drugs that may
have a similar benefit and add them and
I will let dark dark sorry I made you a
doctor again
representative Merchant addressed that
I'm seeing none
at this point I'll ask the clerk to call
the wall on House Bill 223 motion is
octopass
representative land yes representative
Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative matter yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes
representative mazur yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative page yes
and representative McDonald yes
and the vote is 20-0
consent
yes without objection
and when does the report have to be
submitted
um
by the rest of the week I think Monday I
think if we have it in today it may be
able to make it to the next time okay so
no I'll always assume it about it but
I'll try to make it today but um I don't
okay next up is uh House Bill 397
relative to the prohibition of the
possession of hypodermic needles by
miners
um apparently there's an amendment
pending from this on this from what I
understand uh so I would like to
continue this until tomorrow when we'll
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman
um we we had met as everybody knew we
met ad hoc on Monday to try and look at
some amending language just to deal with
some of the some of the concerns I think
we're getting pretty close to that we
just needed to have it drafted so um
hopefully we'll be able to have that
drafted for tomorrow we have agreement
thank you
okay next up is uh House Bill 338
relative to prescription drug assistance
oh okay all right
all right all right why don't uh we have
two we have conflicting schedules here I
tried to be organized but I did it in a
different order I apologize too many
well if you've seen my cooking or tasted
my cooking you'd know
um 6 14 because we just heard that
amendment that one won't be until
tomorrow
okay
um
all right so we're going to also
continuing HB 614 and also be continuing
HB 282
at 6 14 will be continued until tomorrow
and HB 282 will be continued until next
okay now we're going to go out a little
bit out of order
could we know the reason for the
32 we're basically
there's still some discussions ongoing
with trying to
come to some kind of a
you know Focus among a number of us
that's okay and so
three
Thirty so could you go through the list
again of the ones that are going to be
tomorrow just because I didn't catch up
as you were saying them sure I'm sorry
uh hb614 is going to be tomorrow okay
I've got that one and HB 397. okay and
okay what was the last one 282
is that 15th
thank you we're all working off
different lists I know I know
obviously I'm getting confused a little
bit too so
yes representative Shapiro
so in regards to 282 of which on the
sponsor I'm not sure what you meant by
this ongoing discussions but
um
if there are ongoing discussions and it
would be helpful I would certainly
welcome being part of those okay
absolutely
I appreciate that
foreign
so again we're going to go a little bit
out of order here and jump over to 590
HB 598 relative to funding maternal
is there a second to that motion second
representative McLean seconds
representative Palmer I'm sorry I'll
raise the other hand next time
I was Bill 598.
representative Merchant would you like
to speak to your motion
right yes I would thank you Mr chair
I think the intent of the online bill is
well intended
however to take money out of an existing
program and transfer it to another
program
I think is ill-conceived we heard at
least I did and testimony of how the
other program is working fairly well
they rely upon this funding and to take
the funding out of that stream
you'll have a significant impact on
their organization I think domestic
violence is extremely important and as
the legislative body we need to continue
to support it so therefore I'm opposed
to the bill as is written
and I would like to recommend which I
did ideal
thank you
oops
sorry
you have to be smarter than the plug
which
is
comes Downstream
oh
yours yours is working it's just the
ones Downstream of you that are gone
because it has only one position works
sure
um
mine is working all of those are not
working because but anyway the point
that I was going to make was that
we were given a fairly robust
discussion
of maternal mortality and
um I think that given that we have a
significant body of uh research already
on that in this state
uh it's not necessary
uh particularly to divert funding from
other
equally important sources uh
particularly as it was pointed out to me
the the difference in numbers between
um
maternal mortality reviews which is a
very important thing to do
on the one hand and the number of
victims of domestic and sexual violence
in the course of the state
many of whom also are killed so
um
I'm that for that reason I am going to
vote against the bill and I'm going to
try very hard not to unplug anything
anymore and I think I thank my colleague
for her assistance
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair I I too would support
itl and um I think the intention of
making the maternal mortality review
more robust or strengthening it is uh is
something I would absolutely support and
I know we're not supposed to attribute
motives but um I would attribute
positive motives to the representative
who brought the bill I absolutely trust
his good intentions in making up for the
funding for domestic violence funding
but I just don't think that that's the
way government should work that we
should take a promise from one person
and
um make that the reason to do something
I think you know had this bill come with
text about how each of those programs
was going to be funded and that they
were going to be funded at an adequate
level or the same levels for domestic
violence I would vote for this but I
just don't think we should run
government by taking one person's
statement that I'll make this work
so I'm going to vote against the bill
thank you representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman um one of the
strange things that I did when I ran for
office was I promised to listen to my
constituents and um I was very much
impressed with the number of emails that
I received in opposition to this and um
in in honor of that I'm going to vote to
itl
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman
um I I was actually quite troubled by
some of the testimony we heard from the
domestic violence group that none of the
money was going to salaries and then we
heard testimony from one of the
beneficiary groups that that money did
go to salaries I think that there's more
to look at within the domestic violence
fund but I don't think that this bill is
necessarily the right way to do that I
think that we already have a clear
signal of the substance use disorder and
I think that perhaps looking looking at
making sure that those important
domestic violence monies actually go to
benefiting these these women and men
because men are also victims of domestic
violence but to make sure that these
people can be empowered and go from
being a victim to being a Survivor and I
think that that's worthy of future study
but um I but because of that I prefer
something that's a little bit more clean
so I'll be building itl
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative land
yes representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Nutter yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Pelos of yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
Freitas
representative Cannon yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative page yes
representative McDonald yes vote is 20
to zero there's no objection we'll put
this on the consent calendar
okay next uh for our consideration is a
house bill 264
relative to amendments and corrections
to birth records representative lay on
do you have a motion uh yes I move to
retain house bill 264.
is there a second uh representative
mazur yes second please uh would you
like to speak to a motion representative
Leon uh yes thank you Mr chairman
um I think that a lot of the spill is
straightforward because we have other
documents that reflect the the sex on
the driver's license and passports and
it would be retaining a copy within the
records my biggest concern here is that
we have an opportunity to make sure that
the state or our schools haven't failed
anybody in the process we have a very
straightforward path a relatively
straightforward path in order to change
your gender once but if you're returning
to your birth gender
I I want to have a mechanism of
reporting if somebody feels that they
were failed by policies that that's
heard because it's because it's a
challenging it's a challenging landscape
and it's one that that
presents personal issues it it's very
sensitive and I want to make sure that
the state is sensitive to it and also in
addition we heard that without by
getting rid of the court order as a
process there may not be the way to have
the name change and there's a couple
technical issues too so I think that
this is something that we can we can get
to a good agreement on but I don't think
that we're quite here yet and I really
really do want to make sure that anybody
switching back has their voice fully
heard if they have anything to say and I
want to make sure that that's secure
that safety net is there
okay any other discussion
representative Cannon
I can go along with that we can do some
additional work on it make it better
thank you I look forward to doing that
okay saving none
uh I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative natter yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative mazur yes
representative Nagel
representative Weber
yes
representative McKay
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative page yes
and representative McDonald yes
the vote is 20-0
thank you
next for our consideration is House Bill
re-establishing the special supplemental
nutrition program for women infants and
children otherwise known as WIC Farmers
Market nutrition program
um representative Cushman do you have a
motion yes I move that we
recommend HB 574 in expedient to
legislate
second
discussion uh representative Congressman
do you want to speak to your motion yes
thank you Mr chairman
um moving this Ito as we heard in the
testimony that there are other programs
available to allow food stamps to be
used at farmers markets and we heard
also in previous years that this program
was not re-established because of the
low uptake in the the alternative
programs in place and there's a sizable
um amount of money going into this and a
large chunk of that is State funds and I
think that this bill should be laid to
rest this session
of the discussion
I'm trying to figure out
I have two separate amendments and I
have now gotten my amendments confused
uh this is the one for which we were
trying to insert the words or forms that
road signed Farm stands
and at the request of Representative
Leon and I have an amendment that did
that and then
um
at
unfortunately I think I have now
I still haven't managed to correct the
problem with the first amendment that we
had uh but I would certainly although I
am not prepared to offer the right
Amendment on the right bill because I
got the wrong Amendment in haste last
time
um I would oppose the itl because I
think this is a good program I think we
ought to get it in place this term this
season and as we heard there are
mechanisms for dealing with it so I am
the discussion
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I believe that if we do move
forward with this program we do need to
include roadside stands but I do think
that the large states spend when we're
dealing with when we're dealing with
larger larger issues in the economy
which I know impact food but we also do
have other mechanisms to get money at
these farmers markets and these roadside
stands right now we're flesh and money
I'm just very very cautious in what we
do how we stand it up and the low
utilization rates that we had
um this is one where when the chips fall
on one side or the other I don't think
this is quite this is the right year at
this point but if it does move forward I
would like to see that roadside stands
are included
uh representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um you know I'm not sure I understand
but I remember
hearing that the state money
appropriation was money that would then
be reimbursed by federal money and that
actually the cost of the program would
be paid for by federal monies I'm not
I'm not totally clear about that but I
wonder if
someone in the committee it looks like
someone on the committee is ready or
someone in the audience can answer that
for sure
um I don't know that I can answer it for
sure but I did speak to the prime
sponsor and he thought that it was only
Federal money then looking into it and
trying to talk to the talking to the
department
um there's also State money so that it
goes from a ten dollar annual benefit to
a 30 annual benefit in order to make it
more meaningful so part of the process
from last year when it was just the ten
dollars was that it was sweetening the
pot with some State money so that it'd
be a more sizable amount but this is
still going to be a one-time field trip
to a roadside stand ten dollars or
thirty dollars that's the question do we
get into where we take out the state
money put it into Federal and sunset it
or say right now we already have this we
have a question about if we're going to
require these Farmers to take it it's
complex it had a low utilization rate
and we have other really important
processes to work on as well so there is
confusion over whether it's state or
federal but my understanding is that 200
000 of it is State money in addition
addition to seventy thousand to support
the program on those to support the
federal program
approximately
representative Weber
uh I was just going to make the point
that
um were the policy committee and where
the health policy committee and I am all
in favor of anything that gets fresh
fruits and vegetables into anybody's
hands under any circumstances and it
this is a an early bill so it will be
going to the finance committee after
this to live or die in in the pot with
all the other good policy that people
come up with so I'm very calm I'm very
comfortable passing it as a matter of
Health policy and leaving the funding
questions to the place where they really
ought to be decided
of the discussion representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman I'm going to
vote against itl as well and um I know
that we are all guilty once in a while
of using Hyperbole and um it's probably
hyperbole to say that this is going to
change the nutrition will have
nutritional habits or the nutritional
intake for the people who use this it's
it's just thirty dollars one time a year
and so I don't want to make that
argument but I would make an argument
similar to representative Weber's that
this is a bill
that supports Farmers it supports the
right of people to enjoy fresh fruits
and vegetables and
um to some extent I see it as symbolic
or educational
but I think it's something it's it's a
small amount of money
and I think it's something we should
encourage so I'm going to vote against
itl and I hope that we'll get to vote
representative Leon um I apologize but
one other point I agree we do want to
make sure that people get fresh fruits
and vegetables there's actually a a
program where we're able to get seeds
from the Department of Agriculture and
hopefully everybody on this committee
will help share that to families because
they can get seed packets so they can
grow their own garden in a little window
box even if you just repurpose your five
thousand dollar egg carton
representative Shapiro
um because I'm a fan of public libraries
and also because my wife works at a
public a small Public Library
um I think I I would just like to say
that also a lot of libraries are now
um providing seeds for people and our
local library in Keene is also providing
all kinds of tools so you can go garden
and um
and
education as well about gardening so I
think those go hand in hand I think we
should pass the bill and celebrate that
libraries and other people are giving
out seeds
okay I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
motion is itl on 574.
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Nutter yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay
representative Freitas no
representative Cannon
no
I'm sorry I can't
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
representative page no
10 to 10.
is there another motion that someone
wishes to make representative Weber I
move out to pass
motion's been made ought to pass is
I just wanted to make the notion the
mention that because we don't the word
Farm Stand is already included in the
def Federal definition of the program so
we know they can be done but I
absolutely take representative Leon's
point that it would be better to have
the words or Farm stands in the bill so
in the event that I am writing a report
for a committee that perhaps does not
have a recommendation
I would be writing it ought to pass with
an amendment to be numbered later which
would include the Farm Stand language
which makes the beer Bill clearer and I
just wanted to make sure everybody knew
that up front that I was not pulling off
pulling a fast one my intent is entirely
to
any other discussion
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um I will be voting against the ought to
pass motion
um I I can understand the point that
it's a small amount of money
um
you know and you know it may give some
benefit to a small amount of people but
I think that the number of people is
very small and I think that the
utilization is not guaranteed especially
if transportation is an issue and these
people are getting farm fresh vegetables
at the supermarkets that they go to
anyway there are local
supermarket Local Foods in our
supermarkets
the other thing is this is all coming
from taxpayers and we're going to have a
budget that's you know a lot of money
and the the more that we can Whittle
that down and reduce the burden on our
taxpayers I think the better I think
everyone is suffering right now in this
economy and we need to look at the big
picture and see is is this really a
benefit that's going to actually help
enough people I think that all people
who are taxpayers in the state can
benefit from not paying as much out of
their pocket
being none I will ask the clerk to
follow all motion is ought to pass on
574.
and just for clarity uh representative
Nutter Upham did you second
okay
representative Leon no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King no
representative natter no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel no
Representative poloso no
representative Weber yes
Senator McKay yeah
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Gary Merchant yes sorry
about that representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes
representative page yes
and representative McDonald no
okay are there any other motions to be
I think if I understand the committee
and what are all saying the intent is
the policy itself we support
there's been some discussion about the
mechanics of it
I don't like to have more bills retained
because it just needs more work for the
committee how are they given the fact
that nutrition is important
to go to youngsters is dealing with WIC
women and infants and children
I'd like to retain the bill but I'm
leery of it because we have enough bills
already retained so I'm looking around
my committee peers and saying we retain
it that also means we have additional
workload
I'll make a motion to retain it
representative Merchant moves to retain
is there a second
who seconded it or a tie you can call it
okay representative McKay we'll we'll
let you second it
um would you like to speak to your
motion representative Merchant more than
you have already or
I think I pretty much covered it all
so at this point in time
the intent is well done I think we have
to work through some of the logistics of
it so therefore that's why I wanted to
retain the bill
um and hopefully other people can see
the merits of that as well
okay thank you uh representative Weber
I'm very much in two minds about
retention
first of all it loses us an entire
season
and we're talking about a very small
amount of money for a very small amount
of people but it makes a very large
if I force us into if I vote to force us
into
voting this term then there is the
possibility the bill can't come back
next term
but
I have to say
I'm really leaning towards let's get
this out to the house and vote on it one
way or another because otherwise we are
currently as a committee descending into
the never-ending story and if we retain
every bill that is going to come 10 to
10 in this committee
uh our summer and our fall is going to
be very difficult but we're also
uh not doing the job the tough job that
we were elected to do for our
constituents so
for that reason I'm leaning against
retention but could be convinced
I actually have a question so if the
representative I'm sorry thank you Mr
chairman so if the bills 10 to 10 it
goes to the house for am I correct If It
ultimately has no recommendation it goes
to the house floor without a
recommendation yeah thank you and and
there is a written report
on both sides
representative I guess I'd like to see
representative Shapiro
um thank you Mr chairman
um
we grow most of our own food at least in
the warm months but every once in a
while I'm at the farmers market and I um
go egad it is so expensive to show up
here I mean
and then I think about the people who
are selling their food who got up at
four o'clock in the morning and have
been picking that food in the fields and
might leave the farmer's market with a
lot of their food unsold so I think it's
um
really difficult to be a small farmer in
New Hampshire and um
I just want to point out that this bill
also supports small farmers once again I
don't want to be hyperbolic so it's not
going to be that much of a support
but it it is also supporting people who
are providing local
frequently organic food which is an
incredibly difficult thing to do so I
want to support those people as well and
I think
as representative Weber said if we
retain it we lose the year of people
being able to do this I think we had a
similar or same bill last year and we
didn't pass it so that we already we
already in a sense retained it although
we didn't work on it so I would vote
against retention sometimes a feel-good
bill is a feel-good bill and it makes
you feel good and it does some good and
if people don't utilize it
then it will it won't be utilized and
the money won't be spent
yes
thank you chairman McDonald I'm against
retaining the bill I feel like we've
already voted on it twice let it go to
the the Full House and just be done with
it uh retaining it is just kicking the
can down the road and I don't think
that's fair to anybody thank you
another discussion representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman this bill was
heard in its twin form in the Senate
today in Senate Bill 233 so if it
survives the Senate we'll be seeing it
either way
um and I just do want to speak to the
idea of supporting the small farmers I
wasn't able to get fully briefed on it
but out in California where all the good
strawberries are grown there's a process
to get that into it oh yes Babalu
they're the best
there's a process of getting that to
people that need it and I'd like to see
us take more of that path but it's a lot
more work than I've been able to
undertake so far so I would look for
partners on that
representative Missouri
yeah I know we talked about before about
even like transportation and a lot of
farmers markets are you know more Rural
and a lot of our under-resourced
families are in urban areas so and with
gas prices and increasing is I mean we
say thirty dollars but then the cost of
getting to these farmers markets and
then as it was mentioned the cost of the
produce at these farmers markets is
significant
um so I I just think there's more
involved in it than Farmers providing
local farmers providing Goods there's
the transportation issues of getting to
these places as well that I've heard one
a few people mention but like that's a
big thing so
um and who knows gas prices could even
continue to increase and make it almost
impossible for our under-resourced
families to get there
of the discussion yes representative I
just wanted to give the big city
perspective of Nashua where the farmers
markets right downtown and within
walking distance of thousands of people
I know but anybody on that side before I
go back to the site
okay representative Nagel I just did a
Google um for allowed to do that but
there's farmers markets in Manchester
Bedford Derry because I have the same
concern you had
but like when I grew up the farmers went
to the city we had a great indoor Polish
market in downtown Buffalo and yeah but
there's plenty of that that issue seems
to be a problem for me
okay
any other discussion
okay so
um motion's been made and seconded to
retain
I'm hearing conflicting opinions about
whether we should do that but I guess
we'll call the roll and see where we end
up
representative land
sorry were you trying to get recognized
or was there a point of order I was
after the discussion listening to the
committee I was willing to read
retract my motion if uh representative
perfect
yeah yeah
you were driving your second
representative McKay
okay so the Motions were drawn
all right so we're going to send 574 to
the floor with no recommendation is that
the will of the committee
okay
uh
thank you Mr chair I was sending it as
amended
sorry what what I will write as as the
and I will let the clerk know that I'll
write the report on the the statement we
call them in favor of
ought to pass
um I I will as I stated write it ought
to pass with an amendment which doesn't
actually change the meaning of the bill
at all it just makes clear that a piece
of the federal legislation
uh which is or Farm stands gets put in
the bill and that's what the amendment
will do and my report will specifically
say that that's what the amendment does
but we having not
achieved a consent none of these things
have been adopted I mean itl hasn't been
adopted and OTP or otpa hasn't been
adopted so it's just a matter of
putting two statements in the calendar
and letting the House vote
okay
okay uh so this this will go to the
floor with no recommendation
our next build for us to consider is
House Bill 565 FNA
which is relative to expanding Medicaid
to include certain postpartum Healthcare
Services representative Leon uh thank
you Mr chairman I move an Expedia to
legislate on House Bill 565 FNA
okay is there a second oh second
representative Cushman seconds
representative land do you want to speak
to your motion um yes thank you Mr
chairman right now we're in very
challenging times around Medicaid
Medicaid expansion the expiration of the
public health emergency and all of those
implications over the next nine months
we are going to have tens of thousands
of people and notified about the
necessity of continuing benefits and
there'll be major shocks to the Health
Care System
right now
right now it's just a matter of
expanding the benefits that we have
while we're going through such a major
change just does not seem wise to me at
this point and therefore that's why I
any other discussion yes representative
I oppose an expedient to legislate this
is giving
uh
women a good start with their babies and
it costs us very little money and it's
federally matched to extend benefits
from two months to 12 months if you want
to build a healthy Society if you want
to cut down on drug abuse abuse all
kinds of things you start with building
healthy children I'm so in favor of this
bill
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman
um
this bill was defeated the house bill
last year was defeated
and voted against in this committee but
there was a Senate bill that an Omnibus
Senate bill that included this that was
passed and when it went to a committee
of conference while people didn't
disagree about this part of the bill
they did disagree about other things and
it never made it through the committee
of conference so this just barely didn't
pass last year the idea for this bill
did not come from the representative who
presented it it's not something you know
it wasn't her brainchild this is a bill
that is an option that is created by the
federal government
and it's specifically to deal with the
high rates of maternal mortality in this
country
the most recent statistics of the United
States are that 17 they're 17.4 deaths
per 100 000 live births and that is well
above
um most of the other wealthy countries
in the um in the world including Poland
which has a rate of 1.1
um
the Czech Republic that is 4.5 so it is
a recognized problem that we are trying
to solve that the country is trying to
solve so we shouldn't think of it as
just the New Hampshire solution
um
we have heard that two months of
postpartum coverage
does not catch a lot of problems that
happen Post
delivery of a child and that included
cardiac problems and it included mental
health problems postpartum depression it
included the sequelae of substance
misuse and because we got a report about
maternal mortality related to the other
bill on maternal mortality
if one looks in there you can see at one
point there were maternal mortalities in
New Hampshire
and um about 40 percent of those
maternal mortalities came between
I think it was 43 days and one year so a
lot of the deaths that we have
experienced in New Hampshire come Beyond
two months
the last point that I want to make is
that
currently
we cut off
um postpartum benefits for two months
not for everybody who is on Medicaid and
gives birth but just for a portion of
the people there are a portion of the
people who make under under 133 percent
of the federal poverty level that come
two months after their birth they will
continue to be um eligible for
the granite Advantage Health Care
Program expanded Medicaid and they will
continue to have Medicaid it's the
people who have Medicaid by virtue of
the fact that they were pregnant and
they have to be under 196 percent of the
federal poverty level so it's only a
portion of people that will be expanding
postpartum benefits for
and
um
someone who makes just a little bit over
133 percent of the federal poverty level
which is 19
391 dollars
um for two people I don't know if you
counted as two people once they have the
baby
um it's twenty six thousand dollars so
these people who will have their
Medicaid cut off postpartum or people
who are working at very low wage jobs
very likely to not have any health care
benefits so I think we are taking
low-income people people who are
vulnerable people who are vulnerable to
these um
maternal mortality and maternal medical
problems and we're turning them out in
the cold and I think that um I I agree
with the representative who said we're
dealing with a lot of things in terms of
Medicaid a lot of changes and a lot of
unknowns
um but I think this is just
um
really good
child
family
Health Care policy and that is the job
of our committee to increase access to
health care I mean at least that's the
mission that I see for our committee so
this is incremental it's small
but it just makes total sense to me and
so I would vote against itl and
hopefully vote for autopests
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um I would disagree with the last
statement
um I don't well I agree that we as a
committee can help improve access to
health care but
um I don't think that necessarily means
you know subsidizing it with taxpayer
money and
you know the broader we make eligibility
for Medicaid the more people are on
Medicaid eventually everyone will be
eligible for Medicaid and then we have
Universal Health Care and I I think we
need to draw a hard line somewhere and
right now there's no eligibility
requirement to continue this benefit
past two months postpartum as the bill
is written and someone could be making
you know plenty of money once they go
back to work and still taxpayers are
footing their medical bills
in addition I don't think that there is
this extremely high need as we've only
had nine
maternal deaths as we heard from one of
the person people testifying on this
bill and most of those deaths were
attributed to drug overdose so it it's I
I don't think that this is a wise way to
spend taxpayer money just because the
federal government is matching doesn't
mean that we have to jump in and join
um
I think that
um in New Hampshire you know we we are
fiscally responsible and I think that we
should continue that and vote itl on
this bill
of the discussion yes representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman I just have
a question I can't find my notes on this
bill was there uh we had a dollar figure
foreign
we did not have a dollar amount it says
due to time constraints the office of
the LBA is unable to provide a fiscal
note for this bill is introduced at this
time so unless that's changed and we
haven't been notified it's it's an
unknown representative nabel um do we
have a number of people
that was involved is that in the bill
I'm sorry I left my notes somewhere
I I believe there was some talk about
that from the testimony but I I do not
have those figures and I'm not sure that
that's what those Figures were
representative you had your hand up or
yeah I actually wanted to make some
other points
um I I will rummage through my stuff but
I will make the first point is that uh
we should be acting on good health
policy
and leaving to the finance committee
because this is also an early bill I
believe
uh
yes uh the question of whether the funds
are available and how they relate to the
need of all the other things we have
need of
um
the other points I wanted to make on my
own bat were
um
only a few people die
and that's bad enough
but a lot of people have as we heard in
testimony
uh severe consequences attendant on
having given birth that only show up
after two months
and those problems as we know in many
many contexts
if left untreated are going to cost a
lot more to treat
when we get to the point where somebody
winds up in an emergency room then they
are if they were treated with routine
well-mom and well baby care
prior to becoming an acute episode so
that was my low-lying fruit and I will
try and see if I can find the other
numbers but I'm drowning in paper here
so
um
representative Merchant
sort of enforce what representative
Weber said I don't think this as so much
as an expense as an investment
um we have a tendency sometimes be very
short-sighted
and the consequence comes back to Midas
and when you're dealing with children
and health
it's a lot easier to spend a dollar on
prevention
then it's 100 on Curative
and this bill basically is trying to
identify women as well as infants
and get to them early enough to have an
intervention to make it as cost
effective as possible from a policy
point of view it's good health policy as
well as a fiscal policy but to
representative Weber said it's actually
a finance to determine but I see this
more as an investment versus an expense
number two talking about representative
Leon I cannot think of it any better
time
as the Department of Health Human
Services is going through eligibility
reviews then to put this into the same
review process and saying the eligible
so we're not adding the workload we're
just making it part of the review
process they're going through today so I
don't think it's going to be a
burdensome to the department because
they're going to have to go through this
uh representative Leon and then
representative Weber
um thank you Mr chairman
um we do look back to some of the things
that were discussed last year when a
very similar bill came by there was a
lot of discussion on that testimony
about if New Hampshire could have
certain limits like keeping the income
limit that allows you to qualify while
you're pregnant during that next private
pregnancy but the federal government
will not allow us to do that if we sign
on I know when I shared my personal
experience it became a little bit of uh
just one case but we're looking at a lot
of these just one case if we can save
just one woman
or else we also need to look at some of
those other consequences that do come
from it when I was pregnant with my
first child I was laid off because 95 of
my company was late my department was
laid off because we were acquired so had
I been unmarried or if my husband had
not been working I would have qualified
for benefits and then I went back to
work I had another closely spaced
pregnancy and it may have made a lot of
sense for me to be saving it to space my
pregnancies closer in order to save some
money I know there's a large cost to
raise a child to adulthood but when
you're able to consolidate and keep
things closer there are some some
economies of scale of Health having
children closer however the World Health
Organization highly discourages
pregnancies that are more than two to
three years apart so I am also very
concerned about the health risks of
women who are in that margin in between
where they can where they're getting or
can afford very high quality care and
then choosing to make economic choices
to tie themselves back in or to get
pregnant again faster so that they can
maintain that Health Care coverage
because I know today there are young
people that are not going to hire higher
employment and better opportunities
because they don't want to go off of
Medicaid that they got during covid and
that's one of the issues that's
impacting our employment Market I know
that people are smart and they follow
incentives and I truly do see that as a
risk for some of these several hundred
women who are here and that has health
risks too because tightly spaced
pregnancies increase the Opera increase
the chance of adverse health effects in
I'm sorry representative Weber and then
I'll come over here
um
the memorandum that we got from Ms Dyer
the committee researcher uh was based on
last year's figures and said that the uh
Department had estimated an annual
increase in state general funds
expenditures between 200
000 and a million dollars per year so
that's
I know that's a big number but I think
in the course of the grand scheme of
things it's a very small number to pay
for
the infant a good start in life and the
mom the good health to go forward in
life and I would take exception to the
idea that somebody incurs the expense of
raising a child for 18 years because
they want to stay on Medicaid for
another 10 months I just if somebody is
making that balance
it's a strange credulity in my case so
uh that that was the money issue yes
representative King
thank you chairman McDonald
I could talk for a long time on this
bill and because it's so similar to so
many other bills I have a philosophical
disagreement with this entire idea I
won't bore you with that one thing I
will say though is that something just
one one topic that's not being mentioned
here is what kind of care earlier we had
somebody come in and talk about
naturopathic medicine and the
establishment stooge came in here and
told us about how terrible naturopathy
is and you know what are you if you're
on Medicaid are you going to get
naturopathic no you're not so so for me
it's like great we're signing them up
for the um the big the big corporate uh
grift that's in bed with the government
and they're going to get allopathic
medicine they're going to get you know
an allopathic medicine might be great if
you've got a broken leg but you know if
you have chronic illness I'm a big fan
of naturopathy and they're not going to
get this they're not going to get that
with this so what we're doing is we're
just shoe warning more and more people
into an entire medical system that I'm
just disgusted with so I don't I don't
want more people in that I want to get
people off of that thank you
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman um and I don't
want to pile on any more than what has
already been said about
um the bills pluses and minuses but you
know it's it's very clear I think in the
literature when you talk about social
determinants of health and preventative
medicine Etc
that this sort of Bill and this sort of
investment has a tremendous return on
investment the well-being of the mother
the well-being of the child
um you it's it's an exponential you know
benefit that is gained by supporting
them and but the point I wanted to make
is that this is not Universal Health
Care for all
this is talking about the additional 10
months
when the women are most susceptible to
postpartum depression cardiac disease
all of the morbidity that comes with
delivering a child and so we're not
talking about an extended period of time
that they're on exorbitant costs that
the government the state will will have
to support when you think about a third
of women's deaths in the postpartum area
is related to cardiac disease that could
be prevented with good care so we're
talking about a very short period of
time but the period of time when they
need it most so I would support this
bill
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair
um Mr chair um we had this bill and we
had another like it um which had to do
with providing uh coverage for uh legal
residents and I think from my
perspective if I kind of look at those
bills in isolation that kind of makes
sense because you know they are
providing value for some of the for some
of the reasons that representative uh
Murphy outlined but I think you know to
to address the concern raised by
representative weberware is this good
health care policy and I think while
while the intention is good the idea
that we keep moving more and more people
into Medicare to to provide this I think
we're just putting everything in in one
bucket and I think there may be other
ways that um we could be doing this it's
interesting that all the bills that we
have coming before us have to do with we
can put these people into Medicare we
can put these people into Medicare and
we don't really hear a lot about what
about the exchanges and I know from
personal experience that I have a lot of
colleagues of mine who kind of fit in
the middle between Medicare and employer
insurance and so they're forced on to
the exchanges and it's really
unaffordable and but I don't really
think it's getting any attention and the
continued attention just seems to be
we're going to be putting it into one
bucket I think at some point it kind of
has to stop and and so I think that is
where it gets into is that Sound Health
Care policy or not and so I think we
could continue to go down this path of
adding this and that and everything else
just into the Medicare but I think we
have to be exploring other avenues and I
I think that we could just be keeping
adding into the Medicaid bucket for
forever so I'll be opposing the bill
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I'm hearing mention that that
additional pregnancy would only get you
10 months if you conceive in that last
month that gets you 10 months plus nine
months of pregnancy plus another 12
months so that's 31 more months of
coverage if you conceive again at the
end of that that year then that's 52
months of coverage that's over four
years of Health Care coverage for
spacing bursts that would otherwise be
desired to be more greatly spaced let's
say you want a family with three
children
instead of waiting longer there is a
great incentive to space them closer
that increases the chances of postpartum
depression it increases the adverse
cardiac events for women this is getting
incentives misaligned and it also is
removing more and more people from the
marketplace which has systemic impacts
on our Health Care system if you really
take out that middle and have it so it's
all either government provided or
employer provided with no space in
between and there's not enough people to
keep that sustainable it's going to push
one way or the other and that's just
going to end up pushing more and more
people onto Medicaid so that's why this
is a policy issue and not just a
spending issue
representative Nagel
um since we've used movie references
earlier I I feel somewhat like Tom
Tuttle a Tacoma on this bill I
um can see both sides of this very well
from my medical perspective I've worked
with the Indian Health Service with
impoverished people I've seen the
positive and the negative effects of
such incentivization can do to people
when Medicaid was originally created in
the 1960s it was never created with the
idea of permanent Medicaid it was
created with the idea of helping people
with a safety net with the idea of
giving them incentives to get off and
become something more of yourself and I
agree with your point that um that we
kind of lost that and we need to get
that back with that said
um
pregnancy especially single pregnancies
and entire incredibly vulnerable period
of time
um my cousin since we're showing
personal stories as well my cousin um
got pregnant at a young age
um had a child funded by Medicaid my
cousin's doing really well for herself
her then child now daughter is also
doing very well for herself so she's
very much a success story
my concern with this bill was not that
my bill was the 12 months and that and I
did ask them where does this 12 months
number come from because I think
because of everything
um representative Leon said and I've
worked with people that basically get
stuck on this system for a lot of
different reasons and it's not good for
anybody it's not good for them it's not
good for us
um but I I was struggling with the 12
months and I basically seemed to get a
bureaucratic answer if I had my way I
would rewrite the bill and and change
that number to something other than 12.
um and I don't have the brains to figure
out how to do that but I don't feel very
comfortable with the number 12 for a lot
of reasons so
I basically just said a lot of nothing
and I'm still waiting for you to help
convince me what I should do about this
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
I suppose many of you wonder uh where I
got my white hair from
uh
the
patients that I've seen over the years
with with this condition
are some of the most frightening people
to work with that I can think about
I can think of one person who got onto a
motorcycle going 90 miles an hour with
the baby
and
and I was still fairly young then so
that's when it started that that is not
only in the other part is that even
though people are denying this they're
talking more about money than they are
Health well with it and that concerns me
because the
uh the dangerousness of
everybody
including the therapist
is at stake in this kind of uh work and
I'm lucky to be around at my age and
contrary to some rumor that's going
around I am not the oldest member of the
legislature a good friend of mine is uh
and and I don't think that
issue at all uh but that my feeling is
that people in the mental health field
are under a tremendous pressure
constantly and that this is one of the
greatest uh problems
to deal with and that anything that we
can do to make this world better for
these individuals
all the better thank you
another discussion
representative Weber
I would just say an answer to
representative Nagel that I would be
delighted to write a compromise but the
federal plan is a bureaucratic answer
and it's either two months or it's 12
months but it's not
nothing in between is is allowable so
um it's for that reason and I simply
come down on on the opposite side of
that dilemma
representative palazzov
thank you Mr chairman uh I I don't want
uh smart Investments and investments in
postpartum health and that's why I will
be voting against this bill because if
we make Services free it's uh when
incentives
are not smart and we will see over
utilization of some health care services
we see we will see longer lines and we
are already
have shortage of some medical
professionals so I want smart
Investments and this is not it thank you
representative Palmer
thank you Mr chairman
um and I guess I feel like since
everybody else has spoken I need to so
I've been advocating for medical care
for the last 20 years and so my one of
my primary focuses has been expanding
care to people who need it and I think
just a couple of things I'm not going to
repeat everything everybody said but
um in countries that provide totally
free care what they find is that people
don't abuse it they
um they use what they need in countries
that don't provide care we have the huge
problems we have which is
over utilization of the emergency room
and um and the lack of preventative care
that ends up costing us a lot more we
have the ERS are backed up with
psychiatric patients they're backed up
with patients who can't get into the
hospital right now and part of that is
because we under invest and we haven't
taking care of the basic problems the
psychiatric issues are we don't you know
there's no place else for these people
to go but the ER so funding programs
like this takes one more little piece
and and really helps a group of people
that need help that prevents long-term
problems that leads to lower costs in
the long run one of the problems of our
Patchwork system is that the cost that's
get lowered may not be in the same
Medicaid Program you may save money
somewhere else it may be saving money in
that this the child of this mother grows
up to be a normal person and ends up
with a productive life and contributes a
lot to society that might not have
happened if their mother had driven them
off the cliff and a motorcycle because
she was depressed so I really do support
this bill
okay
yes representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman
I'm I'm well aware that we have
philosophical
divides in many respects on this
committee
um
you know I think we probably have
disagreement about the um
about Universal Health Care or
single-payer health care we probably
have disagreement about what creates
dependence and what um creates
self-reliance I know we have
um
but I thought we had agreement about the
importance of children having a strong
start in life and strengthening families
I think we do and somebody else referred
to well
I don't think Medicaid should be the
answer to everything what about other
things to strengthen the families and
strengthen children's beginning in life
and I would agree wholeheartedly with
that that I don't think this is the only
solution to build strong families and to
give children a chance
I think there's a lot of other ideas and
we should be pursuing those ideas as
well
but I do think this is one very
important
um
piece to that puzzle
um I think people who um
don't have health care at critical times
in their development for the mother
for the child they don't use Health Care
they have less access to Primary Care
and this is a critical time to help
build strong families and to build
um
good Beginnings for children starting
out in life and so
[Music]
um
guess I hope we can put those other
philosophical
disagreements aside and do this for
families and do this for children and um
will it incentivize people to have
lots of babies quickly I I don't I don't
think so but I don't really know and I
don't really want to get into a
discussion about that I want to do
everything we can to support
strong families and um and children who
are beginning their lives will it
possibly create some dependence
um I certainly couldn't argue I've
certainly worked with a lot of people in
my career who were dependent on
government subsidies I realize that
that's a problem but I don't think
that's the priority here the priority is
getting people off to a decent start in
life thank you one or two more questions
and then I clearly this is the toughest
Bill we've dealt with representative
King
thank you again chairman McDonald I'd
like to address something representative
uh Palmer mentioned with all the respect
I disagree with one thing and I think
representative politsov would probably
be in a good position to attest to the
fact that in many countries uh where you
know all their medical care is provided
the reason why they're they're not being
over utilized is because the care is so
bad they know that going to the hospital
means death so um there's a lot of
places where you might get free health
care but that means really really really
bad Care number one number two
um we're looking at a lot of countries
that a lot of people have promoted over
the years like Canada as like the the
Nirvana of socialized medicine and now
we're getting the point where it is in
such disarray euthanasia is really
starting to kick off not just in Canada
but in the Netherlands and other places
so
um yeah that's what's happening is they
are they are running short on nurses
there's a huge nursing Supply crisis
there so just shoehorning more and more
people into the government if you hate
people do that that's my last statement
thank you my last question last comment
representative primer
um so the countries that I was talking
about are first world countries that
have really excellent Medical Care
and I think if we're going to go further
down this what we need to do is get some
statistics to back our stories up and we
could go on for hours on this but
thank you it's clearly the most
difficult Bill we built with that what
I'd like to do at this time is called a
brief Republican caucus for about 15
minutes I think we could all use a
little bit of a break and we'll be back
back at 3 20. uh 3 20. was that yep
that sounds right
foreign
okay thank you everybody
um it's been a long day
and uh a lot of healthy debate here
um
we've heard just about from everybody
unless anyone has any pressing comments
remaining on 565. I would like to
proceed with a vote at this time
so anybody who has any strong passion
about any final comments on 565 and the
seeing none I'd like to ask the clerk to
call the roll
again 565 motion is itl
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative natter yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Weber no
no representative McKay no
Representative friedas no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer
no
representative
page no
and representative McDonald yes
and the vote is 10 to 10.
I'm not sure quite the order you want to
vote on this but uh what I would like to
202304h all zero three zero four h does
was when we heard the bill we were told
that there had been a reenactment of the
statute that we were operating under and
this gets the right Statute in the right
section and we'd had an earlier
effort with that amendment that came out
in an amended section one incident of
section two I had the amendment that I'm
proposing now
properly amend section two
thank you
okay well it's usually appropriate to
take up an amendment first okay so
so you're moving that Amendment so I
would move Amendment zero three zero
four h and
um I would state that all it does is
and I I haven't passed it out I will
pass it out if you'd like it but all it
does and I'm anticipating a certain
result with this vote
um
all it does is amend
the line on line three and four it's
section 5113 of the Consolidated
Appropriations Act of 2023 as opposed to
whatever we referenced earlier there was
a second to representative Weber's
motion
second representative Merchant
proceed representative do you have a
further comment on this sir uh no I just
I I would hope that people would adopt
the amendment just in the name of
correct citation and then we can go on
to whatever is going to be the fate of
the bill
thank you another discussion on the
amendment
seeing none
representative Leon yes
representative representative Cushman
this is just on the amendment correct
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative
pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas
yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes
representative page
and representative McDonald yes
20-0
representative Weber and then I would
move ought to pass as amended on House
Bill 565 FNA
any further discussion on the main Bill
565 is there FNA is there a second on
that
I'm sorry is there a second yes
one second please
okay who did you take it to the second
so I can write it down
and I don't think there needs to be any
further discussion I don't think so I
think we've talked this I think we've
covered it pretty thoroughly from all
sides
uh I have no idea but pick any I mean I
know that Representatives Nutter and
Champion were both waving there and I
know representative Cannon was Raising
representative Leon no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King no
Representative notter no
representative McLean nope
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel no
Representative pelosov no
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Palmer yes
representative page yes
and the vote is 10 to 10.
consistent with our last bill do we want
to send this to the flow without a
recommendation
okay and
Mr chairman I will just consult with the
people who voted on the ought to pass
side and see who wants to write that but
if if no one else does I will okay great
I appreciate that
and you'll send that over to me when it
absolutely all right thank you thank you
okay moving on
um
House Bill 413 authorizing advanced
practice registered nurses and physician
assistants to prescribe diabetic shoes
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I move in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 413.
is there a second second representative
Nagel seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Leon yes thank you Mr
chairman
um looking into this I saw that
um Physicians assistants within their
scope of practice are already authorized
to prescribe drugs and devices for
advanced practice nurses they're
authorized to prescribe therapeutic
measures and in everything that I've
seen therapeutic measures includes drugs
and devices it's one of those areas
where the citizen legislature didn't
Define that well but I see no
limitations on that currently I
appreciate I appreciate representative
leckis trying to find an area where
practice has been constrained but
fortunately it looks like this is not a
problem so we can we can move in
expedient to legislate representative
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman um I I went to the street to
answer this question but my wife's a
nurse practitioner I work with about 20
Physicians assistants they can already
write for orthopedic shoes they can
write for braces they can write for all
sorts of durable medical things so um
this is actually already covered and and
oh the discussion
representative Merchant
I think I'm talking to people what I
have found out it's not so much the
question of writing the prescriptions a
reimbursement issue
um
representative Weber and I I think what
I heard is that the reimbursement issue
is again one of the ones that's out of
our hands and therefore uh the the
practice issue is already there so I'm
seeing none
representative sounds like we can all
agree to agree
very good that's great
okay I'll ask the clerk to call the
rolls
okay uh representative Leon yes
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative natter yes representative
McLean
yes
representative Missouri yes
representative pelosov
yes
representative McKay yeah
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative page yes and
representative McDonald yes 20-0
Kim Son
if there's no objection we'll put that
on the consent calendar
okay uh again it's been a pretty full
day and we've got another one tomorrow
I would like to afford to continue the
remaining bills which according to my
records of 338
614 excuse me 548 338
582 and 615 that that coincide with what
everyone else has
I read them on my list in my order so
I'm sorry 397.
I'm asking about the ones that are
continued till tomorrow right 397 is one
yes
okay
no that's hypodermic needles which we
haven't done yet
um 6 14.
uh yes
um and the other two were 582 582 and
615 that's correct okay got it thank you
um 338 yes
okay and then we had
um
this for tournament
428 we already did we did that last week
okay I have a question yes
representative just about the process
the bills that we
um
deferred from today
can we hear them tomorrow even though
they're not noticed
it's we're continuing them until
tomorrow and there was the continuing
notice in the calendar that said that
they were continued from today over till
tomorrow so I think that does satisfy
okay
it was it was clear that there was this
whole chunk and we were going to bite
off as much as we could chew today and
then the rest of them flowed over to the
tomorrow bucket I just didn't want us to
get in trouble it's addendum 10B okay to
the calendar yeah
I think after 565 we lost some steam
a lot of good discussion though
uh so uh
unless anyone has anything else so we'll
reconvene tomorrow morning at uh 9 A.M
and adjourned
oh
I will send you 415 in case they can get
money
and as a reminder if I can see the
Democrats up in 403 immediately
following
and and representative page we thank you
foreign